ابو هشام يقول ان العرب لم تجتمع على شيء
الا على امره شوقي
من اللي اولا اجتمعوا ولا
درن عن امرض شوقي ولا العرب ما درون
السعوديه بكاميرا ما درت عن هذا والله انا
يا بيت المتنبي بيت واحد انه اشهر من شوقي
واخوانه وابنائي وعماتي وخالاتي وجداته
وجدته وقرابته وجيرانه انا ما اسمع في
المتنبي انا بموت بجيني شككته قلبيه
تنقذوني يا اخي خاف الله فيها ابو عمر
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابوه مالح لو سال ابن حزم ما الغرض
الاساسي لكل انسان في اي مجتمع وفي اي عصر
كان بيقول ازاله الهم يقول ابن حزم بالحرف
تطلبته غرضا يستوي الناس كلهم في استحسانه
وفي طلبه فلم اجد الا واحده وهو طرد الهم
الحزن كلنا نعيش فترات ولحظات حزينه بعض
المرات الطول هذه الفترات وبعض الناس تكون
لحظات الحزن اثرها بالغ عليها وعلى من
حوله كيف نتعامل مع الحزن وخصوصا اننا
نعيش في زمن كل المحفزات الحزن والكابه
باتت اكثر الشبكات الاجتماعيه
وخوارزمياتها المشاهير والمقارنه بين
حياتنا وحياتهم الفراغ
الانشغال بالماضي التفكير والقلق من
المستقبل كيف تعاطى معها العلماء والشعراء
كيف يعالجها الدين الايات الحديث استضفت
في هذه الحلقه كاتب الكتاب الذي ذاع صيته
وترجم الى عده لغات كتب عن الحزن فوصل الى
قلوب الملايين الدكتور عايض القرني وقراءه
جديده لكتاب لا تحزن بعد ان نشر
قبل عشرين عاما وابو عبدالله الحديث مع
لطيف ومات عم وضحك يتحدث عن الحزن فتضحك
عن الشعر فتضحك يقول بيت واحد من المتنبي
يسوى شوقي واخوه وولد اخوه وولد جيرانه
فحلقه ماتعه رائعه
قبل ان نبدا هذه الحلقات تتعاطى مع الحزن
والمشاعر من الناحيه الروحانيه وعندنا
البودكاست جديد تتعاطى مع كل هذه العواطف
الانسانيه من الناحيه العلميه مع الدكتور
محمد الحاجي بودكاست ادم تلقاه في وصف
الحلقه او ابحث عنه في اي تطبيق
اما الان
لنبدا كم عمر البرنامج
والله قديم شويه يعني
انت غنيت انا الحين عن قنوات الفضائيه
وصار انجح يمكن من عشر قنوات رائده سبحان
الله اللي يمكن اول برنامج نقله نوعيه في
في هو عندك يمكن في تاريخي والله اعلم
عندنا في منطقه العرب
في انا استضفت
الشيخ صالح المغامسي
وكنت اناديه بكنيته
سال الناس مني ليش ما تقول لي يا فضيله
الشيخ هل تسمح لي اني اقول لك ابو عبد
الله ابو عبد الله اجمل يا شيخ واقرب
للسنه تصدق وهذا اللي يريحني والله انه
اقرب يا حبيبي وتعرف يا رسميه فضيله الشيخ
وكذا حتى اضحك الواحد من جماعته يحب الشيخ
قلت سمحت الشيخ قال لا تزوج لا لا احسنت
والكون يا اخي حتى الشعر العربي
بلا شك كلمت عبد الرحمن قلت يا اخي ابو
مالح منين قريته او تحددني يا اخي قلت
والله ما شاء الله تبارك الله
تكتشف شخصيه
قدامك كان اختيارك
لاننا يا شيخ عندي الحزن هذا بعدين
لانه يبدو انه يمكن حتى تغير
فهم الناس للحزن ولا اثر حتى الحزن على
الناس يختلف عن اول خصوصا شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي صار معقد يصير حزن معقد وليس
بسيط وصار تراكميه الشيخ وسارى مرض ما
يستاسر الا بصعوبه
وساره يقول ابن حجمه انه مرض العالم عقلاء
العالم الله يجعل العواقب سليمه ويسددنا
واياك نقدم شيئا مفيدا يا رب يا رب طيب
بجي على لا تحزن عن الحزن لان الموضوع مهم
بالنسبه لي
بس يعني في نقيض الشهره والعزله او
العزله والعزله هي من الاشياء اللي مكتوبه
في التراث الاسلامي في كل التراث الانساني
الموجوده فكره العزله كتب فيها الكثير
او كتبت فيها كتاب
ويبدو انك انت تميل الى العزله فيها ودي
اعرف اصلا لو بعرف العزله ما هي العزله
العزله هي فيها
شعوريه وعز لكانيه بدنيه يعني شعوري يقول
يعتزل بالفكر عن مجتمع وسموها في مصر تعرف
جماعه تكفير والهجره يقولون تعتزل بشعورك
ولو كنت داخل مجتمع مكفر المجتمع وجالس في
الفندق وفخان خليلي وفي القاهره وفي
المطعم هذه طبعا العزله البدنيه او عزله
اذا اذا خالف الاجماع اذا خالف يعني اني
انا اتكلمت عن التكفير وهجره لاني حاورت
انا اهل السعوديه في السجوننا اخذوها من
تكفير الهجره عندهم فهم يقول نحن نسكن مع
الاسر ولو كانوا كفار وفي المجتمع ولو
كانوا كفار وهذا معه اخر فاذا خالف الحق
والعدل وما يجمع عليه الناس
اما العزله التي الشرعيه فهي العسر
المعتدله التي دعا عليها صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول حتى شيخ الاسلام لابد الانسان
من عزله في المباحات وفي عند ذكره وعند
صلواته وفي قيام الليل وكذا وانا ما رايت
كالاعتدال لانه الاسراف في الخلطه سوف
يدمر عليك الوقت والانجازات والنجاح ويكون
انسان سبهلله مثل ما قال صديقي رحمه الله
وانا اقول صديقي متعمدا غاز القصيبي لاني
تراضيت قبل الموت سنتين وكانت بين اتصال
فيكون يقول انا الغيت العزائم والمناسبات
من حياتي فانجزته وقد قال في مقابلات
كثيره
فمن ينهمك في الخلطه الله يعوضه خير بجامل
ويجامل ويزور هذا وكل ما جاء الواحد مولود
زار هو يحضروا الزواج والعرضه والغلطه وكل
شيء وليس لهم انجاز والعزله ايضا ان ينفء
يعني يعتزل من الحق والخير والعزاء
ومشاركه الناس ودروس العلم والتاثير خطا
انا ارى ان يكون انسان معتدلا وكذلك
يجعلكم
تجدهم في قيام الليل مع الاسره له وقت
عزله بابيهم صلى الله عليه وسلم الاعتكاف
لكن يوم تجده في المشاهد العامه وقت
العزاء وقت الزواج يحضر صلى وسلم في
الضيافه في الاصلاح بين الناس في النفع في
التعليم في الوعظ في الفتيه في خطابه
الجمعه فهذا ديننا يريد الاعتدال ولا يريد
يعني الطرفين المذمومين الذين دائما من
تطور فيهما اخطاء نعم هذا هو الاعتداء
والوحده
متقاربه متقاربه لكن الوحده يا حبيبي قد
تكون اشد عند كثير من بعض العلماء الف
عزيزي العزله ولو سبب الكتاب هذا لو سمحت
يعني
البرنامج يقوم على الصراحه والبساطه وشوف
انا مره جاني هجوم ادبي ليش لاني تعاونت
مع الاستاذ الفنان محمد عبده في قصيده لا
اله الا الله انا ظننت الوقت انه بيرحبون
بالناس يعني ومن يكتب عن التحرر
وبينك الاطياف والمشاركه والله جاني هجوم
منهم جاني سبحان الله انصدمتنا وصرت ادافع
مره محمد عبده وصرت ادهم مره عن نفسي ومره
ارد فضاق بين الامر وارتفع اعتزل هذا
السبب بعتزل شهر
واقعد جوال اتصل عليه والتلفون قال الملك
سلمان كان امير رياض قال تعال ابغاك والله
دخلت عليه وخاب من افترا وهو الله يمسيه
بالخير قائدنا ووالدنا
قال في اعتزال في الدعوه قلت يا طويل
العمر هاجمونا هجوم كثير في الصحافه وكذا
وكذا قال لي اشرف منك سيد ولد ادم صلى
الله عليه
والكلام في القران اللي يهاجموه المشركين
والمنافقين مكتوب في القران وبعدين طلع
المصحف فيه قصه رجعت البيت قال شوف لك شهر
وتعود الى الدعوه ورجعت الدعوه وسويت
قصيده الجماهير موجوده في النت المقصود
قلت لا بد عز العزله اكتبه لانه هو عريب
بسبب لا تحزن قبله يعني جلسات مباركه له
قصه بعدين يجي
فلما الفت اكتشفت ما هي لوحده وما هي
العزله وما هي الوحده كما قلت لك الشعوريه
والعزل البدنيه والعزل المذمومه والممدوحه
فانا اقول بينهم اشتراك لكن وحده اكثر
شيخيا بتاخذ من التوحد وهي الا يكون له
اتصال الى درجه ان يصل الى الانطواء
والانكماش وتصل الى درجه الكابه وهو قتل
الروح واشراق الروح ويسير هذا ترى قنبله
موقوته انا
يعني لما حاولت الذين في السجون ادركت ان
بعضهم عندهم وحده ولذلك ما ينظر المجتمع
الا بنظارات سوداء كل شيء متشائم فهو متهم
المسؤولين بالظلم ومتهم العلماء انهم
غشاشين ومتهم الدكاترهم عنوانيين
والفنانين انهم لا يصلون وانهم يعني انفجر
غير التجار يعني مراقبين او نحو ذلك
اكتشفت انه لما عزل اتاه الافكار
السوداويه في ذهنه يقول دير كان يجي للاسف
انه اذا اعتزلنا فان ذاكرتنا تذهب للخانه
السوداويه وهذا انت ملاحظ في حياتك الان
شوف اذا جلست في الغرفه بتشرب شاهي ما يجي
لك بالنجاحات مثل برنامجك وف والضيوفك
اللي جو وحب الناس لا يقول انت ما تذكر يا
عبد الرحمن يوم كذا كذا قلت كذا يوم سبك
فلان كذا فادركت ان الوحده هذه مدمره يا
شيخ وانهم بغيت تعالج بعلاج علمي وعلاج
طبي من الطفل قصدي والطفله حتى لا تذهب
الى التوحد نعم لكن في نفس الوقت يعني اذا
اخذنا من العزله يعني بتاخذني الى الجانب
السلبي دائما وفي نفس الوقت كثير من الادب
ولا الكتاب ولا العلماء سواء عربيين ولا
حتى برا اليوم ولا زمان تلقى انه ما ظهر
ادبهم ولا ظهر علمهم الا في عندما اختلوا
بانفسهم واعتزلوا الناس اعتقد انك حتى لا
تحزن انك معتزل انا كتبته انا معتزل وسويت
فصل بهذا بما قلت انت قلت الاول العزله
لما انتج لنا المكان في الحمى تعرفه
واعتزل وزائرتي كان بها حياء فريسه تزور
الا في الظلام بذلت لها المطارف والحشايا
فعافتها
ولون العزله ما انت جرم الخلدون المقدمه
لانه كتبها في قلعه ترى بني حسان ترى حور
الجزائر خمسه شهور ما شاف النور ما خرج
فاخرج لنا هذا طبعا العزله اخرجت من
الصرخسي المبسوط عشر مجلدات وقصص كثيره
كثيره ابن تيميه ترى يمكن يمكن ثلاثين
مجلد ترى كان تعرفه وراء
الحديثه دائما يكون عندهم وقت لكن واحد
الخبل يعتزم ولا بيجيك بجنان
يروحون
لا يقرا لكن مثل الرواد وشرواكم اذا اعتزل
بيقرا للعلماء يقرا الادباء يقرا الشعراء
عنده مشروع حياه ولذلك انا اشوف يا شيخ
انا ارى ان الذي عنده مشروع ولا يخصص وقت
من اعتزالي فننجز ابدا لن ينجز اذا ما كان
في وقت يقول انا سوف اعتزل في اليوم من
ساعتين ثلاث فلن يقدم انجازا لا رساله ولا
كتاب ولا برنامج ولا مشروع لانه بيقعد على
متى اجانا مناسبه ومتى جانا وقت يمكن انه
نقدم لان ينتج ابدا انا تابعت المنتجين
يغلب عليهم انه عندهم اوقات مخصصه للابداع
الخليل بن احمد سيبويه قررت حتى فنهم في
التاليف كانوا يؤلف مثلا من العصر الى
صلاه العشاء هذا ممنوع الاقتراب بعضهم من
صلاه الفجر مثل بنت تيمي الى ان يتعالى
النهار عنده ورد وعنده اقبال على العلم
فاللي ما عنده وقت يكون وقت مقدس للانتاج
فسوف يكون عادي طبعا وذلك اغلب الناس
اشتروا عاديين لماذا لانه على حسب الظروف
مره جميل قال معك جاء عزيمه الحاضرين قال
ترى في عرض اليوم قال معكم وش رايك نروح
معزوم عند قال حاضرين في الاستراحه في هذا
لن ينتجون هم صار عادي مساكين بس في نفس
الوقت صعب جدا انك ترفض هذه العلاقات
الاجتماعيه
بتحديد يا شيخ النظام شوف انا عندي في لا
تحزن طبعا بني الكون على النظام دخلت
الكونجرس مكتوب فيه لوحه بني الكون على
النظام للشمس ينبغي تدرك القمر وللليل
سابق النهارده والله يا شيخي اني عشت انا
معز يمكن سبع سنوات كئيب يعني كتنميد صغير
انه عنده وهو مفتي عامر مملكه واكبر عالم
يدير العلم عندنا
عندهم من الفجر الى طلوع الشمس او بعد درس
يذهب للدوام يعود يتغدى السنين الساعه
اثنين ونصف يذهب المسجد من العصر 70 سنه
ينام الى المغرب المغرب استقبال العامه
بعد العشاء استقبالات علميه
وماشي اموره بنظام وتجد شعب لا عنده
مسؤوليه ولا علم ولا شيء وقال ما عندي وقت
الان شوف الان بعض الشباب هل قرات قلت كله
هل قرات عشر صفحات في اليوم قال والله ما
عندي وقت وعنده ست ساعات يطالع في الوزن
هو في نكات ومقارب وفيديوهات كلام فاضي
النظام النظام سوف اي شيخ مناسبه تدعى لها
سوف تجدها في جدولك لها مكان مثلا بعد
العشاء جعله نادر للدعوات لكن من العصر
للع وقت مبارك
ولذلك انا اقول للمنتجين ان كان تريدون
كلكم بصمه في التاريخ ومكان في المسجد وفي
الرياده فخذونكم نظام يكون في وقت الانجاز
ووقت للتامل وتخلب فاو الى الكهف ينشر لكم
ربكم من رحمته ويهيئ لكم من امركم مرفقه
وهذا في دليل على ان من اوى الى كهف
العباده والانثاء والانجاز والابداع
والرياده سوف يجعل الله له فتحا وسوف يكون
مؤثرا مثل ما اثر بنته مياه وسيبويه ومن
خلدون وابن رشد ما فعلونا بشيء انا قرات
سيرتهم بالتفصيل عندهم وقت يومي لا يرون
احدا ولا يراهم احد
فيخرجون بابداعات علميه خليل بن احمد ترى
من عباقره التاريخ
يقول احد السلف ذكروا الشريف في شرح مقامه
اظنه لا يجوز على الصراط بعد الانبياء
اذكى من الخليل من احمد مكتشف مخترع يقول
له وقت اظنه من بعد المغرب لا راحت في في
خص يعني في مثل كوخ يغلق الباب قال والله
اني يغلق الباب ولا يجتاز همي خارج الباب
ويخرج لنا ابداعات العلميه ولذلك اثر في
مسيره الادب وفي العروض وفي الشعر وفي
اللغه وترك اننا كتب نعم طبعا هذه في بعض
يعني
العزله في يوم العادي نختار بضع ساعات
اعتزل الناس فيها بس مثلا العذر اللي
لفتره طويله يعني ابو حامد الغزالي اعتزل
الناس عشره سنين
قصتها ودرست التاريخ منهم الذهبي وغيره
يبغى له تامل لان الشيء ليست عادي هي صدمه
تاريخيه مع الغزالي واذا قلنا للناس كذا
يعني هي في مخاطره ترى لانه هو خرج من
الفلسفه وعلم الكلام تعرف ولما خرج اثارها
لانه ورد على الفلاس ستارتها الفلاسفه
فلما صار ما يدري ان يتجه واخذ يدعو الله
وخذ يبكي ويقول تركتها الفلسفه وسعدنا
بمنزلي وعدت الى تصحيح اول منزلي ونادتني
الاشواق مهلا فهذه منازل من تهوى حبيبي
فنزل ترى من عباقره التاريخ هو وقال
اني ذاهب الى ربي سيهدين كرم موسى فلما
ذهب اعتزل من بغداد وذهب في الصحراء ذهب
مره الى مكه ثم ذهب مره الى الشام وحده
وعنده ركوه وعنده عصا هذا هذه حاله غير
طبيعيه غير خارجه من السياق وانا ما اقول
لاحد سوى نفسك كذا وروح الى استراليا
الان يبيع كوريا لانه بيضيع فلما اراد
الله سبحانه وتعالى خير وعلمه يقول بنتي
سبحانه رجع الى نيسابور واخذ صحيح البخاري
وادرى ان السنه هي الطريق الصحيح لانه ورد
على الفلسفه ولو انه رد عليه لكن لحقت ترى
ما بيحامد الغزالي في لطيفه بين قوسين انا
كنت ادرس في ابها في رابعه اصول الدين
فقال مدرسنا الله يمسيك بالخير باقي حي او
شيء اسمه ربيع الجوهري مصري قال مات
الغزالي والبخاري على صدره يقصد انه
الصحير البخاري وانا تهابلت وانا اعرف
والتخاري الدكتور ترى توفي عام 256
والغزال يتوفي 555 كيف يموت هذا وهذا على
صديقي قال عشان يسمعون يضحكون
فهو مات يقصد وصحيح البخاري على صدره
فهذه حاله تجي وتجري بعض الناس ترى تقع
لهم مثل هذه لكنها ليست قاعده مضطرده ترى
يا شيخ الاستواء المزاج هذا ينبغي ان يكون
عند الانسان نظام في يومه وفي عامه في
مساله العزله والخلطه والانتاج انا مثلا
اقول الشباب الان مثلا تجي الصيف هل عندك
مشروع تختم كتابين او ثلاثه هل عندك مشروع
مثلا كم تختم من القران وتفهم الختمه مع
تفسير وغير ذلك من انجازات مشاريع موجوده
لكن ما عندنا خطط عمليه
وبعدين ايش اللي يصير انه لما تاخذ الشيء
على اني انا بسويه باخذ كتاب كان مثلا في
الصيف يكون صعب بينما انك تقرا بس لو عشر
دقائق يوميا تلقى انك تنجز ممكن 13 الكتاب
في السنه وهي مجرد عشر دقائق يعني انا
اقول من يقرا عشر صفحات بفهم سوف ياتي بعد
عشر سنوات مؤثر وله اسم في الوطن وسوف
يحترم في مكانه
بينما اليوم سبعين قال ما تخاف الله قل لا
اله الا الله
مؤلفه فالقليل المداوم ليستمر فيه الانسان
والله يهديه
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار
المزيد في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
من يعني مثلا زي ابن خلدون هل هو
اعتزاله الناس هذه الفتره كانت ساده في
حياته ولا كانت شيء يداوم عليه العزله
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يعني يعتزل
الناس في حراء وصدقت وسبحان الله في حراء
لما مات الخطاب يتكلم عن العزله جاء بهذا
هو الاصل والبخاري جاب اصل النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يوم اردت صلى الله عليه وسلم
يغير العالم الله اللي بيغير بالعالم
النبوه جلس في الغار يفكر شوف واعتذر ليش
التعبد والتحنس الذي لا يخلو بنفسه ويراجع
معلوماتي في وقت سوف يكون مبعثرا يعني شوف
يكون عاديا فانا معك في هذا انك ذكرتنا
بهذا النص الرهيب ولذلك فيه زيت بيجي هنا
لا تحزن ترى في الله معانا ابن خلدون لا
هي حاله نادره يقول سبب سبحان الله الفهم
السياسي
والعمق عند ابن خلدونه وتصادم مع دول
فوتره ترى راح من تونس الى الشام الى مصر
الى شيء التصادم هذا صورته اورثه شيء من
الرده الفعل المجتمع ولكن نفعه هذا في انه
فهم الدول وفهم الملوك وفهم الناس فاختنى
بنفسه في المقدمه
تنبي بالانجليزي يقول ما انتج عقل بشريكم
مقدم خلدون والعجيب بن خلدون ترى ما هو
مركز على المقدمه هو يحطه كذا هو هو مركز
على عشره مجلدات تاريخه وابشر تاريخه مما
يكره احد ولا ضرب احد لانه انغمس في بني
مظفر وبني زيان خلفاء ملوك يعني طوائف في
تونس وفي المغرب ما يعرفوا احد وفلان كذا
وراح وفلان يوم تم ثمانيه قال هذا كتاب
التاريخ سوف يكون هو الباك او الصاعق ما
يكون قالوا
مقدمه فخلا بنفسه خمسه اشهر في هضبه وقلعه
بني حسان الخمسه نشر هذه هي صارت احسن من
تاريخ اللي كتبه عشر سنوات انا ما يعرف
تاريخ واحد ترى ما يباع اكثر في الاسواق
مقدمته الشيخ ترجمت بكل لغات العالم انا
دخلت باريس في قسمه من كردون وفي امريكا
وانت تعرف هذا وفي الصين واليابان حتى
اصبحت اعظم وثيقه تاريخيه في مسال عمران
في مساله العمران وصار الان علماء يتحدثون
بها كان كلمات شديده وابيات فريده فهذا هو
في حاله طارئه جت بعدها بعد ما تعبى من
العلم والتجربه
واخذ من الناس ترى يا شيخ من جوانب الخلقه
يستفيد الانسان يستفيده يعرف طبيعي الناس
ويعرف الجيد والخطا زي ما اقول من جدل
عرفه الخطا والصح
والنقد واللوي في بيته والنقد واللوي فما
يعرف الا يعرف لانك اذا خلطت الناس عرفت
الغشاش والظالم والصادق والكاذب ثم اذا
خرجت تفرز انت بدات المحطه عندك والاشاعات
والفضائيات تعطيك الجيد وتعطيك فاذا قرات
اضفت هذا لهذا ولذلك لا يبعث الله نبيا
سبحانه وتعالى حتى يخالط المجتمع
وما صاحبكم وصاحبكم انتم عرفته لو بعت صلى
الله عليه وسلم اتانا من بعيد قالوا ما
ندري وما كان يعرف صلى الله عليه وسلم
الناس ولكنه خالطهم عرفهم صلى الله عليه
وسلم معروف وسموه الصادق الامين هذه وهذا
لابد نفهم يعني في الحياه بالنسبه للعزله
اليوم انت تقولون العزله للانتاج والعزله
وكثير من الناس يعني تدعو للعزله لكن لما
بعتذر اقنعتوني الله يعطيكم العافيه وش
اسوي اروح راح اسولف راح اقرا اتعبد اتامل
يعني تقنيات العزله يعني وش اللي اسويه في
العزله عشان تكون العزله فعلا نافعه هو
شوف ما يقدم على العزله الا واحد قد عرفه
كيف يعتزل عنده مشروع اما نجي بناس يقول
الشباب يلا اعتزل وشاب مسكين يعني متعود
على الكستات ومرقص وعلى العرضه وعلى
الهياط يقول له بيسبح ولا بيتدبر القران
وبعدين نعالجه فيك كابه لا هو اقصد الرواد
هؤلاء الذين عندهم مشروع يعتزل بعد ما
يكون عنده خطه او بيني وبينك خارطه الطريق
فقال انا بعتزل هذا الوقت لان عندي كتاب
كذا وكذا عندي مشروع كذا وكذا انا ودي
افهم القران بالمناسبه سبحان الله اليوم
بعد صلاه الفجر وطارح احد الكتاب
السعوديين بعد يقول بعد اربعين اكتشفت
شيئا كاتب كبير قال اكتشفته مشروع القران
الكتاب الخارجي لذلك الله قال عن كتاب
لذلك الكتاب يقول اتركوا الكتب هذا الكتاب
فيقول بديت الان بيبدا في مشروع قراءته
واحد سعودي ايضا رائد انه كتاب افي الله
يشك اعتزل في جبل لبنان يمكن ثلاثه شهور
واخرج الكتاب كان الجيش شكوك على القران
قال له انا ما بسال اللجنه الدائمه ولا
الوعظ والمشايخ ولا المطاوعه بقرا الكتاب
فلما اعتزل قرا ولذلك انا ادعو الان في
برنامج اول مره اقوله في الاعلام الى
قراءه جديده للقران من الجميع وقل له انا
لسال الشيخ ولا واعظ ولا مدرس ولا شيء
بشيء اجعل فيه اولا ان ينزل عليه هذا
الكتاب امي لا يقرا ولا يكتب وعاش في غرفه
في مكه ولا عنده طبشوره ولا سبوره ولا كرم
ولا دخلك هجمه ولا جامعه ولا شاف شيخ ولا
استاذ ولا دكتور وهذا الكتاب انه كلام
الله بقرا واشوف الحقيقه واكتشفها وشوف
كيف تصل الى سوره الناس بشيء اخر قراءه
جديده وسجل ملاحظاتك المبدعين الاسلاميين
سببهم انهم كروا قراءه جديده للقران وانا
رايت بعض الفضلاء الراي يقول علي الطنطاوي
انه في اخر عمري كان ثروتي القران ابن
كرنو ابن قنون عبد الله تعرف المغربي
اعطوه جائزه المغرب الرائد لانه قرى
الثقافه الفرنسيه والثقافه العربيه قالوا
ما هو الكتاب اللي خرجت به بعد ما قالت
مكتبتين فرنسي وعربي قال كتاب الخالدي
الازلي القران
فانا كره جديده علشان لا تقول ان المشايخ
علمونا باشياء وانهم يعطونا
ويعطون اقرا كلام الباري وانت وقسم نفسك
يقولون بشر كان يقولوا بشر هذا وهذا نعم
طيب بس انت الحين يعني هي اختصرت العزله
على
الرواد واللي عندهم مشاريع لكن في نفس
الوقت برضو انا كانسان عادي يعني احس انه
التوقف في حياه سريعه جدا
حلو تتامل توقف تقول انا مش انا انا اسوي
فتنظر يعني
علاقتك مع الناس علاقتك مع اصدقائك مع
اهلك مع ربك يعني
هذا ممتاز ورائع ايش حد ادنى من العزله
هذا قد ذكره حتى انه بنتي من ذكر فتاوى
مجلد العاشر يقول لابد المسلم يعني المسلم
عادي حتى مسلمه من شيء من العزله طبعا انا
اقصد الرواد المنتجين اما انسان يبغى
يراجع نفسه طيب لابد ركعتين
السحر خير منها ركعتين
[موسيقى]
في عزله طيب ان جلوسك مثلا في اذكار
الصباح والمساء تحتاج يا شيخ الى تامل انا
اقترح نكون في في
للجميع حتى للام والبنت والاخت والاخ
والجميع حتى الذين ما عندهم مشاريع
انتاجيه لا بد ان يراجع نفسه في جلسه
للمحاسبه والمراقبه حتى الغزالي في
الاحياء ماذا قلت اليوم قبل النوم جلسه
قبل النوم ترى الاذكار هل اخطات اليوم على
احد الله يغفر لي وينه هل مثلا يعني انتجت
في يومي لانه في اليوم الثاني سوف يوجد
ماذا افعل غدا انا معك فحتى ادنى من عزله
ترى تصلح للجميع حتى للذي يرعى الغنم ترى
لابد له من جلسه من الاذكار وجلسه يتامل
وجلسه يتفكر في غيره وفي مصدري وكذا لكن
يرحت انا بعيدا في العزله التي هي طويله
ببرنامج الرواد المنتجين اما كل مسلم يا
شيخه صلاتنا في الليل او اللي بيصلي في
الليل وتر عزله بين الاذان واقامه تعتبر
قبل النوم عزله اذا قمت من نومك تركت
تتامل في السحر ولذلك سبحانه في خلق
السماء ترى في السحر خلق السماوات وارض
اختلاف الليل والنهار الاتي
بعد بعد نوم طويل وجاء في صفاء ذهن ثاني
انه في سكون وفي خلوه من الكون ولذلك ابن
عباس في الصحين نمت عند النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم فلمحته قام بابي وامي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
يعني كان غرفته شماس ينظر في الافق ونزل
في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف الليل
والنهار الاتي الباب الايات اخر سوره ال
عمران العشر فانظر جعل التفكر والتذكر في
ساعه الخلوه والعزله وهذه لابد لنا منها
جميعا
الحين بجيلي كتاب لا تحزن انت نشرته في
عام 2003
في مفهوم الحزن في المجتمع من ذاك الوقت
الى اليوم
انا بلا شك اني كنت انا طبعا اشعر بهموم
هموم سبب تاليفي وفتح الله يستر الفضل له
سبحانه وتعالى فلما الفته كان الناس يعني
سبحان الله كل ما تقدم العهد الشيخ انا
فيه كلمه فيه لا تحزن ادركتها في الميدان
نقلتها من من سعد الشيخ في وسائل المفيده
وسالتها من عثيمين في مكه رحمهم الله
جميعا قلت يا شيخ انا وجدت كلمه
الغربي عالم النفس الامريكي واسرع علماء
يقول كلما ترفه الجسم تعقدت الروح قلت هو
بن سعدي كيفه عنيزه كان يجيك كتب من بيروت
ويرسل لها منها دع القلق هذا يقصد ونكر
منه العباره وانا نقلت يقول كلما ترفه
جسمك تعقدت الروح الان يا شيخ في كتاب
الامريكي في جرير اسمه بسط حياتك وانا
ادركت انه كل ما زدنا من الوسائل
والتغذيه ومن الاشياء ومن المشتريات ومن
الهدايا واثقنه انفسنا بالملابس كلما قدر
الحياه الهم والغم شوف حياه البساطه حياه
ابي وابي وجدي وجدك ترى كان بسيطه ما
كانوا يشعرون بالهم
البقر تشتغل من هنا والغنم والرعيان
والمزرعه وكانوا يضحكون يبتسمون هل سمعتم
شيء من شيبانه شكل كابه ولا عندنا مصلحات
نفسيه عندكم او عندنا او في السعوديه ما
في الصحابه احد منهم قلق ولا كابه الصحابه
كلهم وكانوا في في جوع وفي فقر وفي قتال
وفي حرب وفي يعني شده السبب يا محب انه كل
ما نحن
نترفه فنعقد انفسنا ولذلك ينبغينا ان
انادي الشباب انا نعيشوا ببساطه لان
شبابنا اما اتوا الحمد لله
اتت الحضاره واتت المغريات وتنماديات فيظن
سوف يسعدون انفسهم فتجد عنده جوالين ثلاثه
واثنين
وخمسه عقل ويحسب انه دواليب من الفنال
والبدل هو يضيف ترى هموم على هموم وهموم
على هموم ولذلك الامريكي لما كتب وليم
جيمس يوم يقول بسط حياتك يقول انه كلما
ترفه الجسم تعقدت الروح شوف صاحب الثوبين
او الذي يركز على الاشياء البسيطه كيف
ينتج في الحياه ويتخلص من الاشياء حتى
يقول هو يقول انك اتلف الاوراق الفارغه من
جيوبك وتخلص من الاشياء وتلف العوادم التي
لان بعض الناس يحتفظ باشياء ويسجلها وهي
اصلا تكثر علي الشيخ من مشاكل الحياه
البساطه هي طريقنا الى الى ماذا الى
السعاده ولذلك ترى اسعد الناس كان
في غرفه هو عائشه رضي عنها كان هنا
المقلطه بس الغرفه وهنا الحجاب وهنا الجره
وينام بها بصغنم على على سرير الخشب اسعد
الناس وابهج الناس ولذلك ولا سوف يعطيك
ربك فترضى وكان يقول مبتهج دائما اكثر
تبسم فراينا الناس ورايت انا والله من
الاغنياء الذين عندهم طائرات خاصه
وفنادق على السواحل الدافئه عندهم عقاقير
يتناولونها لطرد الكعبه واني رايت الفقراء
يزرعون في المزرعه ويحسدون ومع البقر
والغنم ويضحكون صباح مساء ويتبسمون
ويغردون كما تتغرد العصافير والطيور يا
اخي المتنبي صاحبنا وصاحبك يقول لا تلقى
دهرك الا غير مكترثا ما دام يصحب فيه روحك
البدن فما يديم السرور ما شرت به ولا يرد
عليك الغيب حزنوا غالبا الناس يا شيخ مع
الرفاهيه يكون متشائمين لانه يطمح دائما
الى اعلى واعلى عنده فلتين قال لا انا
ابغى بيت وسيع للعائله خذ بيت وسيع
العائله قال له ابغى بيت في مزرعه وهو كله
وهم ترى
يقول السعاده قرار تتخذ يومي قرار مثل
قرار السياسي ان اقول انا سعيد اليوم وهذا
في الاسلام سعيد ايش لان عندي اشياء ما
فكرته فيها اصلا عندي اشياء افكر في
الموجوده وسبحانه فخذ ما اتيتك طيب عندك
اشياء فكر فيها
تعرفها انا دائما كن مغرب لاني لما قررت
لا تحزن قلت لن اقنع الناس والمثقفين وانا
استفدت الحكمه ضالت المؤمن والله احدهم
ذكرت يقول انك مشكلتنا ان نترك حدائقنا
الجميله وننظر الى اطلال الباليه ترى نبكي
المفقود فقط يقول اشكر الله على الموجود
واترك المفقود لكن من الصباح تجد الشاب
يقول ما عندي وظيفه ما عندي وظيفه انا ما
عندي وظيفه واروح عندهم ويبكي طيب عندك
سمع وعندك بصر وعندك استقرار وعندك صحه
وعندك عافيه وعندك عطل وعندك قراءه وعندك
بيت ما يفكر فيها بس واللي ما عنده زوجة
ما يفكر الا ما عندي زوجه كيف ما تزوجت
كيف ما تزوجت طيب وتسعه وتسعين من النعم
تركتها فالريضه يا شيخ هو قرار قرار مثل
كراسي قرار اليوم انا راضي عندي نعم ولذلك
يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم من اصبح امنا في
سربي في بيته يعني غرفه
معافا في بدنه عنده قوه فكانما والله يا
ابا عمر اني ادركته لما دخلت في عيني
المركزه انما تساوي الدنيا كلها ساعه من
العافيه جلس شهر
وانجت جبال الدنيا وهموم غموض وضع الغنم
في الصحراء يكون راعي غنم بس حافي اثار
عندنا يا شيخ عندنا نعم لا يتقدر ولا توصف
ابدا
فيها تعرف احدهم يقولون من الكتاب طبعا
يقول اتريد في بصرك مليار دولار اتريد في
سمعك مليار دولار احسب ان هذا انه اختراع
غربي فارجع الى السير على من الى مالك بن
دينار عالم كبير كان مسكين يشكو قال ما
عندي كذا ولا عندك قال تريد في سمعك الف
الف درهم
نحن نحمل بليارات الدولارات والنعم
والكنوز في ابداننا وفي انفسهم يا اخي
مشكلتنا نفكر في المفقود ولا نشكر الله
على الموجود ولذلك الرضا اللي يدخل اللي
يريد يعيش الحياه ولا يشعر ولا يحمل لوحه
الرضا الله يحسن عزائه في حياتي ارضي بما
عندك ارضي بما عندك تكون يقول صلى الله
عليه وسلم ارضي ما قسم الله لكم تكن اسلم
اغنى الناس والله من رضي بزوجتي لو كان
غرفه ولو كان حتى في خيمه ان الله يرضيه
ويسمع في الجنه رضي الله عنه مرضعه الرضا
انا رايت في مدار الشاركين يقول ابن القيم
توفي شيخ الاسلام مو شيخ فرايت قلت ماذا
رايت ما هو احسن عمل قال الرضا لو اخترت
انا عنوان الشريعه هي الرضا رضي الله عنهم
ورضوا عنه ترضى يقول بعض العلماء يقدمك
سبحانه ترضى امرك ترى حكيم ارضى منعك من
وظيفه قد يكون في حكمه ارضاء ما حصل لك
ثروه ارضى الرضا هذا هو كنز لكن متى
نستشعره يوم نعلم يا شيخ ان الله حكيم
مدبر يقول يدبر الامر والله اني رايت في
الاخير يا بعض الشيء اني كنت اكرهه في
حياتي واذا عين المصلحه وعسى ان تكرهوا
شيئا وهو خير لكم وعسى ان تحبوا شيئا وهو
شر لكم تدخل في صفقه تقول تجاريه وتكتشف
انك تكون الهلاك لو نجحت
تتجه لمشروع وتقول يمكن ان هذا هو الصحيح
فيمنعك الله عز وجل وتحجب عنه وهي ذا هو
المصلحه كذا ياتيك مرض يعطلك عن اشياء
واذا هو عينه الحكمه منه سبحانه وتعالى
الرضا ولذلك من يشعر بالرضا يا اخي
يقول ايها المشتكي وما بك داء يقول انت
مشتكي الان وما مريض
المركز كيف تقضوا اذا غدرت علينا هذا انت
تشتكيلا كيف اذا مرضت اتر الشوكه في
الورود وتعمى ان ترى فوقه الندى اكليلا
ترى بعض الناس متشائم يا ابو عمر لو تقدم
له الورده قال بس شوفها انك تشوف ترى فيها
شوك ترى هذه شوكيه ترى قال تعال انا واياك
نخرج الى الصحراء يا اخي والله هي النجوم
يا اخي الظلام هذا والله عسف عننا الدنيا
كلها تقول الشمس ترى ترسل اشاعاتها يقول
الاطباء قال حرارتها مني قال لك دايم
محرقنا ولا سويت بنا الى الشمس ما يرد
الجانب السلبي كيف تعدو اذا غدوت علينا
اثر الشوكه في الورود وتعمى فوق ان ترى
فوقه الندى اكلينا والذي نفسه بغير جمال
لا يرى في الوجود
جميله ما يوجد شيء انا رايت يا شيخ لينظر
بعين الجمال ما يرى الجوانب المشتركه في
الناس ولذلك يقول لحد العلماء احسن الظن
وسوف تجد الناس يعني تجد كل شيء عندك جميل
ولذلك يقول متنبي اذا سعى فعل المرء ساظ
ظنونه وصدق ما يعتاد من توهمي يرى الناس
يرى انهم كانهم عدوانين وقال انا جيت حزن
احذر من عقده المؤامره تخلص من عقده
المؤامره قال والله متامرين علي والله
شافوني ناجح ما اندرى عنك ولا درع والله
ما يفكرون فيك مشغولين بخبزهم ومش
باولادهم قال عندي جيران حسبي الله عليهم
ترى قرابتي متربصين بيه ترى الزملائي
شافوني ترى اسمع الكلام يدبرون والله ما
دبره احد لكن عنده مريض فعقده المؤامره
حبيبي ولذلك برشيد من شمر يقول ما يستشك
حسين كود الرديين ولا ترى الطيب بطانه
انظر بجمال واحسن الظن بالناس الله يكافك
بحسن الظن وال طيبين وفيهم خير انا
اكتشفته في حياتي شيء يا شيخ انك بقدر ما
تعطي تاخذ من الناس تبسم يتبسمون اكثر
سلمي ويسلمون اكثر مد يدك مصافح يعطونك
اكثر شاركهم يشاركون اكثر لكن بالمقارنه
الله العافيه من كسر لهم اعطوه لانه
التعامل هكذا هي مناصفه ولذلك علينا نحسن
الظن وننظر في الجوانب الايجابيه من الناس
لذلك يعجبني مبارك انهم كان ما ينظر الا
للمحاسب قالوا فلان قالوا فلان كريم كان
ولكنه حاد الطبع كانه صندوق قالوا فلان
تراه عجوز قال لك الوالدين
[موسيقى]
فلابد ان نسكني على المحاسن وننظر برؤيه
والله سبحانه وتعالى يقول انظر معي في
السماوات دائما ينظر لنا الله سبحانه
يعيدنا الجمال حدا ياخذه
والسماء بنيناها ويعطيك الفضائل والاخلاص
لكن اعوذ بالله يا اخي النفوس هذه النفوس
المريضه دائما تذهب الى الى الشرع اعوذ
بالله والى سوء الظن ومن
مر
مر مذاب مرا به الماء السلاله حتى الماء
الزلال اذا شربه يتحول لان فمه اصلا يمر
حتى يقول متنبي قد تنكر العين ضوء الشمس
مرهمه طعم الماء من سقمي ولا الحياه ترى
جميله وسواء هي في حضاره سواء فيها فقر
سواء فيها شده سواء فيها غنى
اكتشفت يا ابا عبدك في سؤال
اكتشفت ايضا في لا تحزن كاني انا مخترع
يعني ما شاء الله
تتعلم
اعوذ بالله نسيت انما وصلنا ايه
اي انه بقدر ما تنظر يعطيك الله سبحانه
وتعالى بقدر ما تتامل وتظن فيه يعطيك
سبحانه اظن عندها من انا عند ظن عبدي
فليظن بما شاء
قراته ثلاث مرات تعرفون الغربيين حول
الخمسين كان هو يقول كنت اظن مبالغ هو
يقول انت افتح اطباق قلبك للفيوضات
الالهيه المؤمنين بالله مسيحيين يعني وسوف
يعطيك الله مثل ما تتامل رجعت في الاسلام
الى يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول الله
تعالى انا عند حسن
واذا ظننت بالله الخير والله يعطيك خير
حتى رايت علماء يقول كان عالم مثل النووي
واتجه الى الله صار عالما يقول البس
العمامه وانت صغير تقول شيخا بسبب انك
توجهت انت فلذلك رايت في القران وكذا قال
اذا انزل سوره نظر بعضهم الى بعض هل يراكم
قالوا اما الذين امنوا فزادتهم ايمانا
وهم يستبشرون واما الذين في قلوبهم فزادهم
والقران واحد والقضيه واحده ورساله واحده
لكن شوف انظروا اليها بشك وريمه اعطاهم
الله الشك قال فلما زاروا الله قلوبهم
ولمن امنوا اعطاهم الله قالوا هذا موعدا
الله ورسوله وصدق الله ورسوله ترى في
الخندق اثنان
واقفا على السفير الخندق والرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم يحفر ضرب ضربه لمعه بارك قال
اريد قصور كسره القيصر وسوف يفتح الله
عليه هذا الشخص الصحابي قال صدق الله
ورسوله
بيفتح قصور قصر قسم الواحد منا ما يقدر
يروح بيته
صدق الله ورسوله وموعد الله ورسوله صدق
الله ورسوله وما زادهم الا ايمان وتسليما
والموعدنا الله ورسوله
وهو الصحابه هؤلاء دخلوا كثير منهم
وحقق الله لهم الامنيه اذا احسن الظن
بالله لانه يملك كل شيء سبحانه وتعالى حتى
الغرب الان والشرق متفقين على المحسن الظن
بالله عز وجل اعطاه سبحانه وتعالى لكن
تبغى انسان سيئ ظن بالله وسيضن باهله
باخوانه وسيم المجتمع في بعض الناس مريض
يا اخي النعم في الوطن يا اخي وامن وسلام
ورخاء وخير يجيك باشياء قال لكن في ينقص
علينا لا كانه ترى يجي اشياء يذكر لك
السلميات ولذلك انا من النصائح لا تجالس
المتشائم جالس المتفائل لان زملائنا والله
بعضهم يا شيخ ما يملك ريال في جيبي وكان
الدنيا عنده ويضحك ويمزح ويا مرحبا ويا
هلا ويا بعضهم عنده رصيد في البنك وانه
معقود الغضب معه وعبوس طيب وش بتنفع عن
الثروه اذا كنت معيش السعاده انا في نفسي
واسعد اهلي واسعد زوجتي واخواني وجيراني
وعيش السعاده وافرح يا اخي مجرد انك تعيش
ثلاث وجبات يقول انك لن تاكل في اليوم
اكثر من ثلاث وجبات وليس لك معي اخر تعرف
الاطباء
كثيره يستفيدنا من هذه القضيه لانه دخلوا
في الطب وعلم النفس قال ولن تلبس الا ثوبا
وحيدا فاليوم هذا حرص عليه فلن يعود مره
ثانيه فيها نقلت عن غاندي انا في لا تحزن
يقول ان شاعر الدين كان ديليسيا هذا شاعر
الهند يقول شاعر الهند احرص على اليوم
الذي انبثق يفجره فلن يعود مره ثانيه ان
يكون سعيدا يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم اذا
اصبحت تنتظر المساء
وكتبت فصل اسمه يومك يومك انا اهديل
الجميع وقدر ويمكن اعرف منو انا وجدت في
حياتي اني اذا ركزت على اليوم نحن اليوم
مثلا يوم الاربعاء
اذا ركزت على هذا اليوم وقلت سوف اصلي
صلاه خاشعه وسوف اقرا في كتابه مفيد وسوف
ابر والدتي واتصل بان حي مستعاونك بخير
والديك وسوف اكون طيبا مع اهلي واسرتي
وسوف امادح اطفالي واليوم سوف احرص على
الاذكار اتي بها واليوم سوف اتصل بصديق
واليوم اتصل بمصاب او يتم اجبر خاطره واذا
الحياه باليوم ما ضافات والمؤمل وغيب ولك
الساعات التي انت فيها يومك يومك القديسيا
يومك يومك اجمل كلمه قيلت في الكون في
عالم الخلود والسعاده يومك يومك اجمل كلمه
في الكون قيل في عالم الخلود والسعاده
يومك يومك انت لست مكلف اللي ذهب ذهب لا
تبكي عن الاطلال الماضيه عفا اللهم سبحانه
لا تذكر الماضي انت رسبت ضربت حرمت انت
الجاي في علم الله في في لا تحزن تقول
يابانيون لا تعبر جسرا حتى تاتي لا تعبر
خل الجسر والكوبري بيجيك انت خلك تكلم
الان تقول حنا بنصه الى
ما وصلت الدائري يقول لا تعبر جسرا حتى
تاتيه من المعالم التي في الحياه انا قلت
يومك يومك من المعالم في حياتي ان على
انسان يجلس جلسه يفكر ويشكر لله سبحانه
وتعالى يعد النعم ابشرك عندي قائمه
اكتشفتها نعمه العقل ونعمه الصلاه ونعمه
اني مسلم ونعمه الهدوء ونعمه الاستراحه
لانه في اللحظه اللي انا اتكلم انا واياك
يا عمر ترى في ناس في الزناجيل الان
بطفايا وفي ناس ينتظر القتل قصصا او كذا
في ناس الان يفكر في اغواء الناس بالسحر
والشعوذه والزندقه والالحاد في ناس الان
عصابات الاجرام والفتك في ناس قتله في ناس
معرضين عن مسجد الله في ناس يسجد البقر في
كذا في قضيه انك توازن نفسك وتشوف النعمه
اللي عندك جميله جدا منها نعمه يا شيخ
نعمه الصبر انا ما رايته اوسع القوه
الخارقه هي الصبر
الصبر حتى ريان لها كتابه استراليه قراته
نقلت منه في قوه الصبر كتاب رائع جميل
تقول في كتاب العرب القراني لفظها كذا
كتاب العربي القران سبعين موطنا في الصبر
يعني بتسجع الناس يستراليه غير مسلمه
مسيحيه تقول ليس في العالم اقوى من الصبر
سبقها محمد بن عبد الله قال موت يعني
انسان اوسع ولا خير من الصبر الله يا
الصبر يا اخي الصبر هذا والله الذي نفسي
بيده انك تعيشك في الكوخ وكانك في قصر
وتجد حتى يقول متنبي وطاعن وخيلا من
فوارسها الدهر وحيدا وما قولي كذا ومع
الصبر الصبر معين لا ينظر تصبر في الازمه
وتصبر في فقد الحبيب وتصبر يقول وبشر
الصابرين
يحب الله الصابرين وما ينجح الا الصابرين
ادركت ان الناس لينجحون فقط بالعبقريه في
عباقره موجودين في المجتمع لكن ما عندهم
صبر ادركت ان صبر وجاهد وجاهد واستمر ولو
كان متوسطه الذكاء وبدون متوسط سوف يصل
القمه عنده صبر وتحمل وهذا الفارق اللي
انا صعبت علماء يعني متوسط في الفهم
ومتوسط لكن صبر تسعين سنه صار علما
ورايت عباقره وعاشرتهم ما صبروا اصابهم
خبر وما نفع يسار محدود الفهم ومحدود
الاداء ومحدود التاثير وهو ولذلك الصبر
ذكر في القاموس 90 مره
صبر جميل حتى يقول من حج الحموي ان تحمي
عيني ان تراك جعلت قلبي منزلك ما اقبح
الصبر الجميل بعاشقك واجمل الصبر الجميل
يا اخي جميل في كل شيء تجوع اصبر ما اجت
وظيفه اصبر ما جاء شيء اصبر لكنك سوف تكون
رقما صعبا بسبب الص بر نجلس الصابرين
والله يحب الصابرين والله يرضى عن
الصابرين وسوف يصل الصابرون ان شاء الله
باذن الله كيف تستحذر يعني لما تحزن مثلا
تكلم كلام جميل جدا في كثير من النقاط
يعني انا اتذكر
تسالني وتقول لي
ايش في شيء متغيره في حياتك اوكي وحياتي
مليانه بنقاط سيئه يعني بالنسبه لي انا
ذاكر الحين يا ودي اغير شيء يعني اعتقد
اني اسال اغلب الناس يعني الان عندك قدره
تغيير شيء في حياتك في تاريخك اغلبهم
من الاشياء السيئه اللي حصلت انا ذاك يعني
تلك اللعبه
فانا استحضر هذه واقول يعني مفترض انها
لما تجيني المصائب اني اقول انها خيب باذن
الله لكن
الصابر والافكار الثانيه لكن وقت الحزن
نفسه وقت المصيبه كيف استحضر هذه الاشياء
القديمه كيف استحضر هذه النصائح اللي جميل
طلعني من الحزن جميل هو سبحان الله يا اخي
الحزن يقفز على الانسان مثل الجان يتلبس
به ويقول لابد ان يكون عندك استعداد مسبق
لان هذه يعني لحظه الكدر ان تزورك
ولذلك يقول وقت الحزن غير مماكانك طبعا لا
تستسلم انا جربت يا شيخ انت اجلس كذا ترى
يجيك واردات شوي شوي يقول غير اما بجلسه
اما بمشي اما برياضه اما بقراءه اما
بتسبيح اما بحركه اما بصديق تتصل به يا
شيخ الاستسلام الحس سبحان الله كابوس
ياتيك فجاه حتى لو كان عندك قوانين العالم
وقرات كتب العالم مهما كان ولذلك ترى
الحزن موجود في العالم هو ليس المقصود
استئصال الحزن لكن تقليل منهم لذلك رسول
في قمه المعاناه ما قال لابي بكر قال لا
تحزن ان الله معنا
فهو الكلمه الجازمه ولذلك انا ما رايته
الا
تركيبته مع دكتور سعودي في الطائره من
الرياض ان اذكر الان قال يا اخي والله اني
اتي بالاوراد يعني اذكار واذكر النعم ثم
فجاه يقفز علي الحزن هذا كان
ويتلبس بك وقالوا ما في الا نقفز قلت ما
في الا نغير مكاننا ونغير وضعتك وانتبه قم
بذكر قم بعمل قم بحركه حتى لو تدور حتى لو
اسوي رياضه لكنك يعني تستسلم منه في
كتابنا يقول انك اذا استسلمت الحزن في فصل
اثبت احد فانك سوف تصبح مثل السجين الصيني
فان السجين في الصين يضعونه تحت انبوب من
الماء يقطر كل دقيقه قطره وهو ينتظر مكبا
وفي اثناء انتظاري دقيقه بعد دقيقه يصاب
بالجمهور لانك انت تبقى في مكانك ترى ما
يجيك ترى اعوذ بالله الشيطان ليحزن الذين
امنوا قال يا عبد الرحمن ونجاح مشهود بها
قال عبد الرحمن ما تذكر اختلفت انت وهذاك
ما تذكر انك انت
اسالك فيجمع لك لا خذ قرار تغيير المكان
تغيير الفكره تغيير الاتجاه في فصل حياتك
من صنع افكارك ترى اجلس يعني طالبان او
شعبان او اختان بنتان ترى في مكان واحد
ظروف وما سوى وحده مبتهيجه وراضيه ومبتسمه
ووحده مكدره لان خانتها ذهبت الحياه تصنع
حياتك من صنع افكارك هي جمعت فكره كل
ماساويات في الحياه ولذلك انا ارى ان يمنع
الانسان ذكر السلبيات عند العائله ويحاول
في اطفال يقول لا يا حبيبي اذكر لنا نجاحك
اليوم اذكرنا ماذا قدمت اذكر كذا لان بعض
الناس حتى متشائم الان شوف الان كبار بعض
كبار السن متعود عنها قال والله اسمعني
يقول لنا
الوقود بتغلى مره والله سمعنا يقول حتى
الحبوب ما عادت تجي من الخارج ما سمعتوا
الحروب يقول والله حسبنا الله يقول والله
ان في حروب قادمه ما عنده الا هذه
السلبيات طيب بشر يا اخي بشري عباد الله
يقول بشر العباد بشر المؤمنين لا والله
الخير قادم الله مدرسه الشيطان في القران
قال الشيطان
الشيطان يعدكم الفقر ويامركم بالفحشاء
والله يعدكم مغفره من وفضله والله واسع
طيب ناخذ وعد الشيطان ونخلي وعبد الرحمن
والله ان راينا المستقبل اجمل وانا انا
وياك في السعوديه والله اني ارى يومنا هذا
سنه هذا احسن من قبل والمستقبل احسن باذن
الله متوكلين على الله وربنا ما بيفلتنا
وراينا من حياتنا ان في انجازات احسن مما
كان قبل وراينا من رغد العيش لكنه متوكلين
على الله عز وجل لماذا السلبيات تدخل في
حياتنا وتكون هي كابوس في وضعيتنا فهو
قرار مثل ما هو ان تتخذ قرارا اذا ما اتخذ
قرار في جلستك والله يا شيخ النتيجه جلسه
ثانيه والزيت وثالثه ورابع ويدخل الانسان
في كعبه معقد الحزن حتى العيد الاطباء
يعجزون ترى يقول ليش ما علمتنا من اول
فخذ قرار قرار الرياضي انا سعيد طيب هل
ممكن اخذ قرار بنفسي بس اذا كانوا اهلي
ملي نفرض انه في احد من اهلي دائما سلبي
كيف اتعامل مع هذا يعني ممكن اكون ايجابي
بس هذه الاشياء يعني خصوصا مثلا لما
يكونوا مثلا كبار السن ولا غيره شلون تقدر
تتعامل مع هذه الاشياء بلا شك انا
زرت الهند نفس مدينه طاغور ولايتك التي
تعرفها انت يقول ليس الناس وملائكه وليست
الدنيا جنه هم شعراء من الكبار اذا عدت
خمسه من العالم هم من حجم محمد اقبال
شكسبير هذا للدين الرومي سعد الشيرازي هو
وحدهم يقول ليست ليس الناس وملائكه وليست
الدنيا جنه صح
ملائكه قضيه السعاده انك يعني ما تلغي
الزميل السيء وواحد متشائم وعندك قريب لك
وعندك ابن وعندك ما تقدر لكن نفسك السعيده
هذه انت سوف تعطى عليها يعني سوار انهم ما
يقتحمونها بالحزن لا بتواسيهم حتى يقول في
حدود طاقتك لا تكون انت
الى درجه انتهلك معهم ما هم مطلوب منك انك
تسحب الغريب ويسحبك هو انا حاولت اسحبك ما
قدرت يا حبيبي انا معذور فتدخل على البسمه
وتيسر لكن اصر هو فين عليك الا البلا لست
عليهم بمسيطر لكن انا في نفسي انا ما
بنقول والله يا حبيبي اني لو مكثنا ننقل
معاشي من حولنا ان نتدمر في نفس اليوم
واحد شامت وواحد يبكي وواحد عبوس وواحد
سيء ظن وواحد حاقد وواحد على الجمعه فانت
تذكر الناس حتى يكون المؤمنين ما تقدر
انفسنا ونحاول نساعد الى درجه ان لا
يسحبنا الغريق الى ان نغرق معه نقول والله
ترى النعام خير حتى يجي لباسك يا حبيب
وانا جربت هذا والله ان رايتهم هدوا الناس
لكن ليس درجه انك تنقل البؤساء كلهم الى
سعداء ولا السيئين الى محسنين ولا الحسد
الى طيبين ما تستطيع اذا ما استطع
الانبياء كيف نحن
تصير يعني مثلا
الحين يعني الحمد لله انا احس انه في
فنجان برنامج يعني اغلب الناس
يعجبهم فيهم رائع واتلقى كثير من المديح
لي حتى لا اسحاق
لو الف يعني تعليقات الف تعليق كلهم يعطيك
العافيه او يتكلم عن الضيف او تشخيصته
الدكتور عايد رائعه او استرساله رائعه
تقديمك في ايجابيه كلها
فاذا كتبها الضايق فلاحظ اني ما بين كل
هالنعم بواحد بس قادر على انه يغير مزاجي
ويخليني انتقل من هالمزاج الى هالمساج
صدقت فكره اولا على ذكر البرنامج يقول
كلمه حق ان شاء الله انها حق برنامج فنجان
بصمه في الاعلام السعودي وهو مما فاخر
الوطن انا تابعته ترى ليش ان واحد قال له
اتابع باهتمام واسمع
بساطتك استرسالك دخول ودليل على الناس
يريدون سهره جاده
ويريدون محتوى جميل ويريدون طرحا بسيطا
ترى البساطه يا شيخ من اقوى ما يكون في
العالم
في براون له رساله الثقافه الناعمه يقول
هي اقوى شيء في الحياه ولذلك يوصل
الامريكان بان لا يقدموا السلاح ياخذ
العالم بالسلاح ياخذون بالثقافه الناعمه
مثل فنجان
ولكن في الاسلام سبق وبشرك يقول الى سبيل
ربك بالحكمه
والمعظه الحسن ادفع بالتي احسن هذه الحسن
هذا البساطه هذا التسيير هو النجاح
التعريق اللي بقول لك لن ينجوا من نقد احد
وانا قلت لك في اول شيء الواحد راحت شبوه
تعالى الله سبحانه والرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يعني انا واياك بنسنا لكن في مساله
يقول سبحانه ولا قد نعلم انك يضيق صدرك
بما يكون نحن بشر فسبح محمد ربكم ارى انك
تطالع وتتبسم وتقول سبح سبح وحتى هذاك
اللي قد ياتيك ترى بشيء ينبهك على شيء انك
تنتبه له في البرنامج قد يكون حتى قد يكون
صحيح الثاني حتى لا نعجب تعجب بانفسنا يا
شيخ بتشوف انت
999 تعليق ممتاز يعني معصومين سنه ملائكه
فرخه
الامر الاخر انا ارى انه لو كان خمسين
يسبونك وخمسين يمدحونك فانت مؤثر جدا
ينبغي ان نحترمك ونرفع لك بلغه العصر قبعه
اللي ما مؤثر الشيخ ميت هو حرمت عليكم
ميته فاذا تحزن ذكرتك مثلا امريكا
ان الناس لا يرفسون كلبا ميتا مثلا عندنا
ما ينظرون يا شيخ يعني ما يلتفتون له لانه
خلاص ما قدم شيء ما قدم محتوى لكن
التعليقات هذا وحتى لو كان جاك خلهم جليل
انك قدمت رساله وانك اثرت وانك ابدعت وانك
هذه هذا المجد يبنى كذا يا حبيبي ولذلك
ينبغي علينا ان نصور لذلك واياكم اسمع من
الابيات بحولهم امسيه شعريه في هذا المنهج
جميل ولذلك هنا عليك انك تتبسم وتدعو لهم
يقول للشافعي يخاطبون السفيه بكل قبح
فاكره ان اكون لهم مجيبا يزيدوا سفاهه
وازيد حلما
هل هذا البرنامج فنجان ما رايكم سوف يكون
كل حتى لا ناجح بس سنه نبغى لو كان كذا
عشان نحط شيء لكن خلاص ثبت مثل الشمس بقع
ما عاد يقدر احد يتكلم نجاحك اكبر لغه
عملك في الميدان اكبر لغه من ان ترد ولذلك
انا اخذت ابشرك تاب الله علي وما صرت ارد
ابدا ابدا من الهجوم والكاس يقول ادفع
بالتي احسن اما بدعوه او ببسمه او بتسبيح
فرغم مع الايام يتحولون حتى اذا جاء
مناسبه الصبح مبارك له او اسوي له مع
العلم اني اعرف انه سوى لو فاس وله ضربه
ولا كمني لكمه واستهزا به لكن يقول ادفع
بالتي احسن فاذا الذي بينك وبينه عداوه
كانه ولي حميم مع الايام البسمه يا ابا
عمر والسلام الداخلي سوف يحول اعداءك الى
اصدقاء والدفع بالتي احسن والناجح لا
يلتفت يقول ناجح ينطلق الى هدفه لانه
يقول ذهب الذيب يصيد
فلقيه السلحفاه وقال ودي اتسابق انا وياه
قال فذهب الصيد على الذيب يعني عشان هو
يتحدث معه ان تذهب الى حدثك الطوالي ولا
اعترض عليك احد طيب اليوم على الشبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي زادت من قدره الناس على
المقارنه وحسن وحده من الاشياء اللي تبعث
الحزن للواحد والكدر هنا يشوف
الخير عند الاخرين ويشوف حاجه زين عند
الثانيين كيف الواحد يقدر يتعامل معاها
اليوم خصوصا مع شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
اللي صار اقدر اشوف بيوت الناس فرحات
الناس سفر الناس وغنى الناس انا تكلمت
عنها قبل بيني وبينك وعالجته في الكتابات
منها المشاهير هؤلاء غالبهم يتعمد اما
بقله وعي قله الثقافه قله ادراك انه يظهر
اجمل ما في حياتي ولو في دقيقتين هو يجمع
لك بيذهب الى لندن في طل من
فيصور لك بدلته الجديده والسعه الفاخره
والسياره وكل شيء ويظهر لك انه اسعد الناس
انت مسكين في بيت متواضع وما قدرت تسدد
الفواتير الكهرباء ما عندك سياره
تقول الله المستعان هذا وهو كان ابن
جيراننا ومن جماعتنا يقول الصحيح وقالوا
هو لم يكشف لك الجانب الاخر هو غادرك وما
صدقك في الموضوع وقد سبقني الدكتور احمد
الشقيري
وبينها وسبقوا العلماء من قبل تعال انت
الذي خرج لنا في دقيقتين وخمس دقائق وفي
المالديف وفي ماليزيا وفي كذا وكذا ما هو
يظرفك والله تكتشف يا محب من المصائب
والماسي كل من لاقيته يشكو دهره ليه تشعري
هذه الدنيا لمن العامه عندنا وعندكم يقول
تحت قصه والله ما اخذت دار من حبره الا
ملات عبره وان عندهم المشاكل اذكر واحد
مشهور بدون ما اسميه خرج بزوجته واستعرض
وابكى مساكين معدمين والفقراء وحمس قلوبهم
واحرقك بعدهم بسيارات بعد فتره طلقها واخذ
التربته تهجوه ويهجوها طيب انت للحين في
الطريق هذا انت ذلحين يمكن وهو بعين او
اتاك حسد او شيء ليش تستعرض وليش تكوي هل
انت هذا هل هذا انجاز لنا انا اقدم رساله
اول مره اقوله وانا صادق مسؤول عن في
برنامج لان البرنامج مسموع ورائد
لماذا نحن نشجع سبكنا صالح بن حميد في
الخطبه نشجع التافهين تافهتهم بمتابعتهم
فيزيدون تفاهه لماذا نشجع التافهين
بمتابعتهم فيجدون تفاهتهم من هم الرواد
عندنا والمشاهير لا ينبغيوا الرواد رموزنا
القياديه في الوطن والعلميه
وابطال الصحه وابطال الجيش والحد الجنوبي
وابطال الامن وابطال الاعلام والرائعين
وابطال الهندسه وابطال الانتاج الذي قدموا
الروعه للوطن وعلماء الكيمياء والفيزياء
وغير متخصصات اين هم تجد عندنا دكتور
فيلسوف او دكتور داهيه او طبيب عالمي او
عسكري قدم صدره للسلاح والرصاص في الحد
الجنوبي او غيره لا يذكر بكلمه ولا بشيء
وتجد واحد يا اخي لا عنده علم ولا عنده
ادراك وعنده سذاجه واشغلنا ببدرته وبساعته
واشغلنا المسافر وحرق قلوبنا وشمت بنا
وشمت بنا وحتى في العالم
وتجد الناس يتابعونه فيزيدونه تفاهه فيزيد
خبال وينهب الاكثر ويصير مجنون فانا مع
صار الشيخ معالي الشيخ صالح بن حميد لا
تتابعوا التافهين فيزدادون تفاهه لشيخ خرج
عن الطور الانسان سنه مشغولين بغرفه النوم
قال هذا الفراش انا اشتريته الله لا يرده
احرقتنا قال هذا السرير هو خصيصا صنع في
باريس يا اخي ما يجوز حتى شرعا ودخلت انا
في غرفه النوم طيب تعرف ان في ناس ينام
على الرصيف ينام قصدي على الخصيف يعني ما
يجد انسان بعدين وجبه ياكلها لماذا انت
تستعرض النعم وهذا مذموم يا شيخ الواجب
تحمد الله ما هو انجازك
وفي فرنسا وفي لندن هل قدمت عمل مشروع
وطني اعلامي هل قدمت يعني خدمه للجيش او
شاركتها مع المناضلين عن البلاد هل قدمت
كتابا رائعا هل قدمت برنامج
او غير ذلك ابد هو
الوجه الاخر تعال انت قلت انك سعيد ما شر
اجل انت معصوم من الماسي والله سبحانه ذكر
انه لابد ولا نبنوك
والانفس والثمرات وبشر الصابرين الى اخره
طيب انت يعني ناجم الخوف ما جاك خوف ما
جاك قلك ما جاك مصيبه ما مرضت اختك ما
اخوك ما جاء صدمه ابوك ما مات امك ما هي
في معاناه
ضحكين علينا بدقيقتين والله يا شيخ ان في
سماجه ينبغي ان يكون انا ان تدرس هذه
الظاهره يعني كيف نوقفها لان فيه في احراج
وفي تسخط عند بعض الناس خاصه ما عندهم
ثقافه او ما عندي ايمان قوي يا شيخ يقول
يا اخي سبحان الله فلان والله كان ابن
جيراننا وصار الان عنده سيارات وعنده يصير
قصور وعنده بيوت حتى في الخارج وصار يحترق
الضعيف مسكين وما يعرف بالمصايب اللي عنده
فهذه الشيخه هذا العالم يعني في الدراسه
سوها مؤخرا في امريكا فانه
اغلب الاطفال يسووا عليهم الدراسه 51%
منهم فضلو انهم يكونون مشاهير على ان
يكونوا رواد فضاء او اطباء او مهندسين او
اي من فواضح ان رغبه الناس الشهره وخصوصا
عند الاطفال اليوم ويمكن حتى عند الاهالي
على مستوى العالم كله صارت هي الاهم يعني
عندنا مشاهير في بلادنا نتكلم عن وطننا
يمكن عنده رابعه ابتدائي ليلي محو الاميه
هو شيء اشغل العالم كله وعندنا الرواد
رواد سعوديين ثلاثه قبل فتره رواد فضاء
صحيح جاوبهم لمحه كده في التويتر وانتهى
الموضوع وهم رواد فضائل يرفعون الوطن
ويرفعون التاريخ كله والله يا شيخ اطباء
عالميين يقول لي احد الاخوه ان الاطباء
السعوديين ممتازوا على مستوى العالم شوف
في كورونا وفي غيرها وشوف مثل الدكتور عبد
الله الربيع والذين كذا الكثير يعني ترى
مثله كثير ومع والمهندسين والقاده في
الجيش والجنود ليس لهم ذاك الاحتفاف
المجتمع ويجيك هذا المشغل الذي ليس عنده
علم مؤصد ولا شهاد عالميه وليس عندهم منتج
يعني اعطنا منجز انت نفعت الوطن فيه انما
اشغلنا تعشى في مكان وتغدى في مكان وتراني
والله جوب حركات يا اخي بهلوانيه عشان
يضحكون جرس كارفسكت من على السرير طيب
يمزح مزحه ساخره هابطه علشان يجر الناس
ياتي بحركات يعني صبيانيه
صحيحا فيحسبون الناس ان هذه الشهره ان اتت
بتعب وانها لا يا حبيبي هي
يقول صدق احد المشاهد ترى المشهور ذا
مشهور اسم مشاهير مفاليس مثل مفحط اذا دخل
الحاره مفحط الناس الحاره تجد مئه الف
ساكتين وساكنين وفيهم العلماء والعباد
والصالحين وشرواكم لكن فحط
ليش لانه صوته مزعج في لا تحزن ابشرك يقول
العربات والفارغه اكثر ضجيجا اذا جاك
القطار وساكت القطار يمكن فيه ثلاثيه عربه
ترى في رز وفي ذهب وفي شيء ساكت جت
العربيه تقلقل ترى ما فيها شيء
وهذا الفارغ يا حبيبي اشغلنا يا حبيبي
واشغل الاعلام واشغل وسائل التواصل والله
اني اقول يعني ما لهم نهايه يعني جلست يا
اخي اعرف كثير والله يا شيخ انك تناقشه
ليس في مساله شرعيه ولا طب ولا هندسه ولا
مستوى اعلامي ولا ابداع بسيط لكنه مشهور
بالحركات مشهور بالهبال مشهور بالخباله
فتابعوا الناس يحبون خبل مهبول يعني
ينظرون ماذا يفعل
فتصدروا وصاروا الناس يظن هذه مقصوده لا
يا شيخ نحن والله الشيخ عندنا كنوز والحمد
لله من الطاقات والابداع ما شاء الله
تبارك الله يعني شيء فوق الوصف من العلماء
والاطباء والقائد هو
والمهندسين غفر الله لنا ولكم لكن اقول
يكفيهم مجدا ما قدمه ما يهمنا الطلاء
العلمي سوف يذهب فاما الزبد فيذهب دفاعا
واما ما ينفع الناس
فسيمكث في الارض اقول لهؤلاء المبدعين من
الاطباء ومن القاده هو من العسكريين ومن
المهندسين اثبتوا الحق معكم والتاريخ
يجدكم وسوف تكونون انتم
وامم افعون الناس فانتم تنفعوا الناس سوف
تبقون في التاريخ وفي الذاكره مجدكم ان
شاء الله وهؤلاء اما الزبد فيذهب جفان هل
الواحد اصلا لما يبحث عن الشهره امر سيء
اذا قصد بها طبعا ليس الشهره يقولون في
دفع الفضيله والخير لا باس باشهر الناس
محمد بن عبد الله الراشدين لكن اذا بحث عن
الشهره لنفسها لذاتي هو بدون ان يكون حتى
لو حطم الفضيله او ارغى الوسائل المباحه
لان بعضهم يصل الى الشهره بوسائل غير
مشروعه كالدجل على الناس والضحك عليهم
وابتزازهم واخذه اموالهم هذا مذموم لكن
طلب الشهره لذاتها طبعا في الاسلام ليس
محمودا الا ان تكون طريق لايصال الحق
والفضيله والاشهر الناس الان رموز الخير
والعطاء بسبب انهم ارادوا الخير هم لا لم
يريدوا الشهره لذاتها هذا يعني قاسم او
الفارق في الموضوع فلذلك حنا نحبذ ان
انسان يدعو للفضيله هو الخير والايمان
والسلام والله سبحانه وتعالى سوف يعطيه
ولذلك ابراهيم عليه السلام
واجعل لي لسان صدقا في الاخرين هي شامل
الشهره لكن لسان الصدق يعني ثنا حسن حتى
يقول المتنبي ذكر فتى عمره الثاني وحاجته
ما قالته فضول العيش اشغاله هو يريد يكون
حديثا حسنا ويكون يدعى له ولا كثير
المشاهير يعني تجدهم قتله وسفاكين عبر
التاريخ وظلمه وفجره فما ينفعهم هذه
السوره ضدهم بلا شك ولو كانوا خامين كان
احسن
فهذه يعني لابد ان نفرق بين هذه وهذه لان
بعض الناس يسعى الى الشهره حتى لو حطم يا
اخي القيم وحطم الاخلاق وسار اعوذ بالله
منبوذا لكن يريد ان يكون مشهورا لذلك تجد
بعضهم يتبذر حتى الى درجه الانحطاط ليسمى
ويذكر كما تفضلت في العربي وغيرها بس يعني
واضح انه في يعني عند السلف وفي الشريعه
انه امر ما كان الناس يبحثون عنه كان يقول
لك مثلا ما منعني من ان يجلس معكم الا
مخافه الشهره ليش كان عند السلف
مخافه الشهره وعدم الرغبه فيها ابدا يعني
هو درجه الورى عندهم ومراقبه الله عز وجل
يخشى اذا اشتهر انه تعجبه نفسه ويصبح عنده
شيء من الخيلاء او رؤيه النفس عن الناس هو
من هذا القبيل والا بعضه انتصر على نفسه
وتصدر وصار اماما كمالك واحمد والشافعي
فاوله يحملهم بلا شك ولذلك تجد نصوص في
عدم صلى الله عليه وسلم مثلا كف عليك
لسانك وليس على خطيئتك فكانوا يهربون من
هذا فالجمع بينهم يقول من تصدر ووثق بنفسه
واراد ان يخلص لوجه الله عز وجل وراء انه
يقدم الخير فلا باس ولكن بعض الناس ترى
ضعيف يا شيخ مع الاضواء ومع قله قد يعني
تعجبه نفسه ويطمح فيظل سواء الفضيله
والسبيل الحق يعني للخير
انت الحين مشهور يعني
ومعروف فهل هذه من الاشياء اللي يعني هل
جت فتره وحسيت اني ودي انسحب من هذه
الشهره والله يا ابو عمر تجيني فترات
وفترات منها فترات اجد دعاء الناس ومحبين
وتجد يعني ما شاء الله ثنى وان الانسان
يحب الثنائي صلى الله عليه وسلم لا كان
اني اسمع الثنا قال ذاك عاجل بشرى المؤمن
واحيانا يجي لك حملات ويجيم مغرضين ويجي
سب حتى قلت لبعض المشايخ يقول اصبروا بعض
العلماء صدقني قلت ابشرك انه شبعنا من
المدح والسب وصار عندي مناعه حتى اني ما
عاد تبحث عن اسمي ماذا يقال لاني تركت يا
شيخ انه لا هو بالمدح الذي بيرفعك ولو
بالذنب اللي بيسقطك الان الذين يقدمون
الخير رموز الوطن ورموز الديانه والرساله
تجدهم مهاجمين والله احيانا اتمنى ان يكون
لست معروفا لاني بحينا بتاول ينور الخطا
او لا يعتذرون لك او مثلا تجد ذلك انك لا
تاخذ الطبيعيه في السوق في المطعم في
اللقاء في الرحله من يعني من غثى الناس
يقول الحمد لله اجر محبين فنحن نزاوج بين
هذا وهذا والله سبحانه وتعالى يدبرنا جل
في علاه لا اله الا هو لا اله الا الله
انت يعني من الناس اللي
عرفوهم الناس قبل الانترنت وبعد الانترنت
فرق معك شيء في انواع الناس تعاطف تعاملهم
معك تعطيهم معك انا قبل النت طبعا قبل
وسائل التواصل كان يعرفني محدودين في
الغالب في الوطن في مدننا وكبار السن يعني
في الغالب وعوام وكذا فتجد فيهم العذر
والتشديد ولكن لمن فتح العالم مفتح علينا
شعوب وطوائف واحزاب فسار الجهد اعظم وساره
حتى الهجوم اكثر لانك الان يعني انت يعني
مع الوطن وباسم الوطن وتجد ان ضدك اناس ضد
بلدك وضد وطنك وضد رسالتك وايضا اتسعد
دائره المثقفين عن لا يقبلون الطرح الاول
قد يكون الطرح الاول ممكن تجيب موعظه
وتحضر قبل صلاه المغرب بخمس دقائق وتلقى
اللي عندك لكن لا يقبلون لانه مستوى الوعي
ارتفع انت تلاحظ حتى في برنامج مستوى
الناس الذين يتابعونك تغير يعني تغير
طرحهم يعني الان مستوى التعليم عندنا في
السعوديه يمكن يعني
فترتنا تركي من الدكاتره والاساتذه وحملت
الماجستير ومتخصصين فصرت اذا غرت الان
وفكر يمكن ساعه تصدق نعم لانه الاول نفكر
من باب التغريد امانه وبعدين بتحاسب انا
ما تقول وبعدين بتفسر وتؤول من الاخرين
فيهاجم ويهاجم حتى يخبرني حتقول والله
يقول في هجوم قلت هذه ضريبه الشهره وعشان
هيك كفاره فلا شك ان اصبح الخطاب عالميا
والعجيب يا محب ان رسالتنا رباني عالميه
من اول يوم الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ما
كان معه الا ثلاثه يقولون ما ارسلناك الا
رحمه للعالمي ثلاثه ولذلك بعد هنا وثمانين
سنه بشرك وصلت صور
نهر الراين وسور الصين العظيم فبلا شك
الجمهور اختلف تماما واصبحنا نتعامل مع
الموجود بقدر استطاعه لكن حسابك يعني اذا
في نقد عليه انه اغلب ادعيه يعني ما في
افكار ولا في يعني طرحك والله بلا شك حتى
لو قلت حتى لو قلت الاذكار حتى ناس هزمنا
الناس قالوا انك تعيش في التسبيح علشان
تفر من قول الحقيقه وقول قيمه الحق الاهم
مثل تشوف الان اخر تغريد فيديو عن خونه
الاوطان وقلت ان الوطن لا يستحق البطاء
البقاء وان خائن الوطن ليس له ذمه ولا
ضمير ولا عهد ولا ميثاق خائن الوطن ليس له
ليس له مكان في المراجل يعني من هذا كبير
الفيديو موجود الان نشوف الان التعليق من
اعداء الوطن من الخارج طبعا انت لابد لكن
بكل شرف اقدم هذه لسانه يعني حتى بعض
الفيديوهات انا اتكلم فيها عن السعاده
يخالفونك يقولون ليس بكلامك صحيح لانك انت
ساكن في بيتك جيد ودخلك ممتاز فانت تحبس
السحاب طيب ماذا تريد انا قلت تريدون اخذ
سياره
فلذلك سبحانه والله يا محب اني سرت الى
درجه اني اقول قولوا لا اله الا الله
قالوا تعلمنا الان لا اله الا الله يعني
حنا جاهلين لا اله الا الله فلن يرضى عنك
الناس شوف كل يا اخي سبحان ربي ما رضوا عن
الواحد الاحد الذي خلقهم ورزقهم يقول فصح
البخاري يسبني ابن ادم سيد ولد ادم مشرف
المطهر ولكن ابشرك ان على وكاله ادعس ولا
تلتفت للخلف وانت ملاحظ نجاح الان يتكلمون
شيء علامه النجاح ان يخرج لك خصوم ولذلك
يقول ذمتي من ناقص
امين كاتب المشهور له كتاب 200 فكره قال
اذا قدمت عملا اعلاميا هو ادبيا وسمعته
ورايت الطوبه باللغه المصري يلقى عليك
فاعرف انك وصلت بلاط المجد وان مدفعيه
النجاح اصبح 21 طلقه لك احتفال بقدومك
فاذا وصلت ساكنا ساكتا ولا شيء فاحسن الله
عزاك في النجاح هذه الضجه يا شيخ هي علامه
انك اثر ولذلك قل لي الناجحين والرواد في
كل مجرد تحملوا واصبروا وواصلوا ولا
يثبتونك يعني لا ياخذونك الذين لا يؤمنون
بالحقيقه والذين لا يفضلون يعني انك تكون
رائدا هذه قيمه المجد يا شيخ وقيمه النجاح
وانا انا اشد بايدي ابنائنا الناجحين من
امثالك وشرواك والجميع ان يستمروا في
العطاء ولا يلتفتوا الى الخلف بل هذه
الشخص السهام التي تقع ترى شهادات براءه
على انك وصلت الى ميدان وصرح المعالي
والمجد بحول الله وقوته وهذا فليتفائل
يعني المتقدم ان شاء الله الفرق بين
الشهره والتاثير
نعم الشهره ان يكون انسان له اسم باقع
موجود يعني كمسمه كبير اصبح في مكانه اما
التاثير يعيش مع الناس 24 ساعه كلمته تعيش
رسالته تعيش يسمعونه يرونه يشاهدونه ولا
انت الحين لو بحثت عن واحد رمز من رموز
مثل الوطن او رمز قبيله تجده موجود من
اربعين سنه لكنك لم تسمع له كلمه ولا بيتا
ولا سالفه ولا قصه لكن مؤثر يدخل معك في
غرفه النوم بجهازي في وسائل التواصل في
اليوتيوب في التويتر في غير ذلك فهذا
الفرق بينهما طيب بالنسبه
هذه واحده من الاشياء اللي انت ممكن
تتلقاها في الاشياء الثانيه اللي هي
الام الناس اللي تشوفها اليوم برضو مع
شبكه الاجتماعيه ومعه التلفزيون كيف تصلك
المعلومات
مثلا ليحدث
لاخواننا في سوريا في تركيا من زلازل لما
تشوف الفقر في اماكن اخرى لما تشوف هذه
الاشياء تؤثر عليك كيف ممكن نتعامل معها
الانسان مع كثره هذه الاشياء والمصائب
اللي يشوفها حوله هذا من الحزن المحمود
انا اتيت في الكتاب محمود والمذموم اذا
حزنت لاخوانك وتعاطفت معهم يعني درجه اللي
تستطيع الله ياجرك على ذلك حزن يعني يكون
فعال كيف فعال انك تدعو لهم تتبرع ترسل
لهم مساعدات ما هو حزمه سلمي ولكنك لا
تهلك نفسك
تقتلك نفسك لا
فتحزننا لكن في مساله انت ذكرتني بها حفظك
الله في
في الماسي او في المتابعات الوسائل
التواصل انا يعجبني كلمه الدكتور عبد الله
خليل في الكويت يقول اذا لم يكن عندك حد
مع اسرتك في وقت متابعه الوسائل التواصل
سوف سوف يضيع عليك الجهد
وتذهب السعاده ويضيع التركيز وبعضهم يعني
من علماء نفسه او التطوير الذات واصابه
يقول لا بد يكون في وقت الاسره ليس في
جوالاتنا وسائل التواصل وبعضهم يقدر له
يعني لانه اصلا التسليم الطفل الى جوال 24
ساعه ترى هو يصبح قنبله موقوته ترى تعلم
بعض الناس تتعلم الارهاب ترى بهذه المواقع
ترى الالحاد بموقعه طيب وين الرعايه اين
الرقابه على العقل والرقابه على التراث
والتربيه لانه نقول كلكم راعين وكلكم
مسؤول رعيته ليست الطعام والشراب
وسكر وميرندا وبيبسي لا التغذيه الروحيه
حتى المعلومه لطفلك ماذا تسمع يا طفلي
ماذا ترى ماذا تشاهد لانه يتعلم اعوذ
الزندقه الارهاب القتل التدمير السرقه
الفواحش والمنكرات فاذا كان الاب والام
ليس عندهم سيطر وليس عندهم حق مشروع
والمراه مسؤوله راعيه في بيت المسؤول عن
رعيته والزوجه والاب
فهذه الرعايه اذا قصرنا فيها شيخ سوف ينتج
لنا هما وغما وكدرا شباب ترى اصيبوا
بالكامل بسبب وسائل التواصل وانا رايت
شبابا اطفالا حتى في السعوديه نقلوا
المستشفى قالوا يصيب بالتوتر لانه بقي على
الجوال مستمر كيف وين الام وين الاب توتر
تماما ونقله يعالجونه اخر يا شيخ اصبح في
كابه وفي عزله بسبب هذه فاذا لم نقم بحد
في الوقت وحد في الاشراف وفي الرعايه في
البيت ونتابع الطفل سوف يتدمر في عقيدته
وفي اخلاقه وفي سيرته انا يمكن تحارب ذكرت
هذا والله يا شيخ بعضهم برسائل تاثر بها
في النت لكن وكان في مساحات تعرفها مساحات
الانترنت قبل
قرا مقالات ثم اصبح خارجيا ثم دمر وفجر في
البلد ما في كم يعني ما في رقابه مسؤول
مطلوب من العالم المفتي ان يراقب بجهدي
والمسؤول والضابط والاب في البيت والام
قال كلكم راعين وكلكم مسؤول عن رعيته
يعني مثبته حتى برضو في امريكا وغيرها
لاثر انستجرام وبعض التطبيقات في التواصل
الاجتماعي على المراهقين وسلبيتها في
زياده الاكتئاب يعني والحزن عند الناس
فهذا تحدي يعني ما هي سهله يعني صح انه
نقول الواحد كذا لكن ادري انها صعبه جدا
على الاباء في ضبطها مع اهلهم لكن هذه
برضو من الاشياء الخارجيه على الواحد باقي
الاشياء الداخليه لان لي علاقه فيها مثل
كثره الذنوب والاشياء اللي انا جالس
اسويها اللي ممكن تخليني اكون حزين كيف
الواحد برضو ممكن يتعامل مع الاشياء اللي
من نفسه جميل هو في حال شرعي للذنوب
والخطايا ولو كانت مثل الجبال ولو كانت
بلغت عنان السمات السحب انك تاتي الى ربك
سبحانه وتعالى ولذلك سبحانه هل باقي هل
انا استطيع العبد الفقير المسكين العبد
المملوك عايض اني بقول اعظم من هذا الكلام
قل يا عبادي الذين اشرفوا على انفسهم لا
تقنطوا من رحمه الله ان الله يغفر الذنوب
جميعا ان الله هو الغفور رحيم بل ابشرك
وبشر المشاهدين انه يبدلها السيئات حسنات
بزياده يبدر الله سيئاتهم حسنات لان الله
خلقنا يا اخي من ماء وخلقنا من طين يقول
صلى الله عليه وسلم والذي نفسي بيده لو لم
تذنبوا لذهب الله بكم ولا جابكم من اخرين
يذنبون فيستغفر الله فيغفره خلاص اتوب الى
الله وانس ما مضى الصحابه قبل الاسلام كان
الاصنام وفواحش منكرات طيب صاروا اسلم
وانت وسارع عالم جديد ويبدل الله سيئاتهم
حسنات المشكله يا شيخ انه عقده الذنب عند
بعض الناس تنتهي به الى كابه والى تحطيم
في حياته ولذلك تحط الصالحات
نقول له انت عبد وانت مسكين وانت خلقت من
الطين كتب الله عليك الخطيئه لكن انتم ادم
عليه السلام ابونا حتى يقول متنبي فيك
ابيات متجاوز يقول ابوكم ادم مسند خطايا
وعلمكم مفارقه الجناني رد على العلماء
قالوا خطا لكن قال الغزالي كلام غازي
الاجمل قال اذا اخطات فعود الى الله فان
اباك ادم قد اخطا وعادي ربي فقبر وتلك
الشنشنه نعرفها من اخزن ومن يشاء بابه فما
ظلم اخزن جمل عربي كان يهدر كذا فجاوا ولد
انه صار يهدم مثلك
قال هذه نخزن حنا على طريق الذنب لكننا
توبه ابشرك وابشرك ان في عشر اشياء ذكرته
حتى عشر اشياء امامك امام الخطيئه تعالج
بها الخطيئه منها التوحيد فانه يمحو
الذنوب يا اخي قولك لا اله الا الله شيء
مذهل في عند الترمذي الصقور سبحانه في
القدسي يا ابن ادم انك ما دعوتني ورجوتني
الا غفرت بك على
يا ابن ادم لو بلغ الذنوبك انا نستمع ثم
استغفرتني غفرت الكره وباني يا ابن ادم لو
اتيتني بقراب الارض خطير ثم جئتني لا تشرك
بشيء لا بكره مغفره يا اخي الصلاه انت
صليت المغرب بعد شوي العشاء الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم في الصحيحين اصبت حدا
الصلاه عندنا شيخ الوضوء كفاره الذكر
كفاره صدقه كفاره والله عشرات الاعمال في
اليوم لكن مشكله الشيطان يقول لانك سويت
الخطيه طيب والحسنات والحسنات ابشرك بعشره
امثاله الى 700 ضعف والسيام يعني السير
فقط سيئه واحده تكتم واحده لكن يحسن الذين
امنوا الشيطان يعودكم الفقر ويامركم
بالفحشاء عشان تستمر تدري اني قابلته في
حياتي بعض الشباب رفض يتوبوا بسبب يقول
ابغى اتوب لكن مثل ما يصلح انتم ما هو
مستعد قال ما خليت ذنب الا فعلته كيف اتوب
انا هاي شوف كيف الفهم
يا اخي سبحان ربي طيب الصحابه كانوا
يعبدون الاصنام كانوا دخلوا في الدين الله
ما خلقك الا ليتوب يتوب عليك والله يحب
التوابين وحب المطهرين بل ابن تيمات بشيء
انا ما رايته لاحد من قبل انا فرحت من قبل
ابشرك وكلمت زمرت اراسلهم يقول ابن تيميه
الصديق الكبير يعني الولي الكبير قد
يبتليها الله بذنب كبير ليكون محبوبا عند
الله مفروحا به لهذا المقصد
يريد الله انت مثلا انك تهون يفرح بك
وتكون محبوب عنده يبتليك بذنب كبير ما
تقدر له فاحشه ومنكر بسبب قال لي انا الله
يحب التوابين وحب اذا جيت انكسرت العبد
حتى لما لماذا خلني اكمل هذا يحبك كيف
يطرح بك قال في الله اشد فرحا بتوبه عبده
من احدكم على رحلته مع هذا طعام وشرابه
وراح في الصحراء يعني في بيته نام وهي عند
راسك كان ما هي موجوده خلاص الحلاك
الى درجه وقف الفرح طفح السرور علي حتى
انني من عظيم ما كسرني ابكاني قال اللهم
انت عبدي وانا ربك اخطا من شده الفرح قال
فهو الذي نفسي بيده ان ربكم اشد فرحا شوف
الله يريد سبحانه وتعالى ان يفرح بك وتكون
محبوبا فيبتريك بهذا شوف السبب يعني ما
درسنا المساله كما ينبغي الان ادم كان في
الشجر وكان في الخلد وكان قصدي قبل الشجره
في الخلد وفي ملك في الجنه قال كان في شيء
من العجب عجب عجب راى نفسه في خلد قال
فابت له الله بالذنب فنزل في الدنيا
فاجتباه وتاب عليه وهداه واخرج منه
الانبياء والشهداء والمصلحين والعادلين
فما تدري حتى يقول ابو معاذ الراجل لو لم
تكن التوبه حبوا شيئا اليه ما ابتلى
بالذنبي اعز الناس عليه وهو ادم دمت
التوبه حب ما ابتلى بالذنب عز اليه يقول
بعض السلف ربى سعيد بن جبير رب حسنه
ادخلتك النار ورب سيئاتنا ادخلتك الجنه
كذا حتى موجود في العزل الخطابي ونفذ كذا
عند ابن ابي الدنيا رب طاعه ادخلتك النار
وربما معصيه ادخال الجنه فسرها ابن القيم
وغيره في المدرسه قال فتاتيك المعصيه
فتتوب وتنكسر وتبكي انا اذنبت اخطات اغفر
لي انا عبد مقصر انا مخطئ فيعطيك الله من
الحسنات والثواب ويتوب عليك وتكون هذه
طريق النجاح ويسوي طاعه كان فيعجب بنفسه
قال شوف
العصاه ذولا والمجرمين انحرفوا والله
الناس الوانه وحطنا بنينا مسجد ما عليك يا
رجال قال فين قطفه الله ولذلك المقيم في
كلمه خالده لهم في مدرج ان مقتل نفسي
وتحقيرها يقطع من المسافات الى الله ما لا
يقطعه صيام النهار ولا قيام الهواجر ولذلك
انين التائبين يقول عمر انين التائبين احب
من زجل المعجبين المسبحين انين التائبين
يحبني انك تقول يا رب اغفر يا ربي اذنبت
يا رب انكسرت انه اله عظيم جبار يحب يكون
هذا عبد انا وياك عبيد
ما يحب يعرف فتجد بعض الناس يقول انا سويت
وانا فعلت ولذلك يقول احذر ثلاث كلمات
مدمره
انا وعندي ولي انا
يقول قارون على علم لا انا يقول انا خير
منه ابليس دمر وراح النار عندي قارون عنده
ثروه قال على علم عندي عندك قال تعال خسف
به فرعون قال اليس لي ملك مصر
اغرقك في اليوم ولذلك يقول لي احسن ما
تقول انا مقصر وعندي ذنوب ولي خطايا فيقول
الله ولك غفرته وسامحته واعطيته ولذلك
الانكسار يا اخي لا يدخل على الله بمثل
الافتكار والانكسار فهو من اعظم ما يجده
الانسان والله يا شيخ اني صاحبت بعض
العلماء الاخيار لافضل منا بدرجات وجدت
فيه من انكسار والتواضع وكذا واني صاحب
بعض الناس يعجب بنفسي اذا سوى اي مشروع
دوخ الناس ويعلن عنه وقال خلاص يا رجال لا
ويستهزئ بالعصاه ما تدري وش العواقب يا
اخي يمكن العاصي الذي تراه لو حسنه او
خبيئه او دمعه عينه مره من مرات او ان
الله تاب عليه او كتب الله لو توبه او له
والدها مره ما تدري ما هي بالمظاهر ولذلك
ينبغي علينا نعذر الخليط يا شيخ ونلتمس
نعذرهم لا نقول انكم اذنبوا لكن اعذرهم
فاننا لا نشمت بهم ولا نشهر بهم وايضا
ندعوهم بالتي احسن ولكن ما ندرين عند
العواقب عند الله سبحانه وتعالى فهو
سبحانه وتعالى ابصر ولذلك ليس فيه في
الدنيا مشكله الا له حل الحل عند الله
ذلحين اخو يوسف الكبير لما ذهب وجاب اخيه
كما تعرف ذلحين تورطه يوسف اخذ اخوه مسكه
ورجع هو مع اخوانه قال لن ارجع لن اطرح
الارض حتى اذن النبي او يحكم الله خير
الحاكم جعل مسالتين ما برجع او يحكم الله
قال جعل الحق الحل عند الله جاء الحل
جمعوا باخوانه وجاء يعقوب وجاء امهم وجمع
الشمل واتى يوسف نبي وصديق وعزيز وسجده او
يحكم الله لي الحل عند الله
وانا اقول دائما وغيري الذي افضل مني يقول
ان الفرق بين الحل بين المسافه بين الحل
ومشكلتك كما بين جبهتك والارض ولذلك
القران فاسجد واقترب السجود الطويل يمحو
الهم الثقيل وانت جرب وانت جربته المناجاه
مع الله كيف يحل سبحانه وتعالى والله
سيجعل الله بعد عسر يسرا وانا لو اخترت ان
اجعل على شاشه جوالي ايه تذكرني في 24
ساعه قلت وعسى ان تكرهوا شيئا وهو خير لكم
وعسى ان تحبوا شيئا وهو شر لكم والله يعلم
وانتم لا تعلمون لا تكره من امر الله شيء
تعطى الامر زواج ما حصل مشروع ما تم هو
الاختيار منه هو الاصطفاء سبحانه وتعالى
نحن في تدبير سبحانه وتعالى اهم شيء نحمل
وثيقه لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله هي
في عالمنا
طب في بعض الناس
يبدو ان حظه عاثر فتلقى وظيفه ما تضبط مع
زواج ما يضبط مع
علاقات ما تضبط معاه يعني كل شيء كذا الا
ما تعين تضبط كيف يتعامل مع هذه يعني هذه
تعطيه برضو شيء من الحزن يعني في حياته هو
صح هو اعرف ان الارزاق هو فهم الناس
الحياه الشيخ ان الارزاق رزقا واحدا فرص
عندهم كذا الرزق والفلوس الارزاق مختلفه
هذه اردت انا نسيت امس نسيته والان تذكرته
في اول حلقه لا تظن ان الرزق هو دائم
وظيفه وفلوس ورصيد في البنك
الارزاق يوزعها الله على ميسان بعضهم
يعطيس عتبان ولو كان ما عنده وظيفه وبعضهم
يعطيه صبر وبعضهم يعطيك قناعه وبعضهم رضا
وبعضهم يجعلك كفارنا وبعضهم استقرار في
نفسه صاحب
يكون عقيما قد يكون مقدرا قد يكون عنده
جوانب اخرى فليش نحن ليش نفهم الحياه كلها
ما حصلت وظيفه ما في فلوس انه هي الارزاق
تعالي يا اخي انت عندك اشياء وعندك ام
قد يكون رزقك الله بها سبحانه وتعالى
الامر الثاني لا نعطيه مساله احباط نقول
خلاص ترى انت ترى ما كنت محظوظ انت نصيبك
من اخبرنا العلم الغيبه نحن لا نقول تعال
في فرص سانحه
طبعا نعود الكتاب يقول جرب البحث عن
السعاده كما تجرب النمله فانك النمله تصعد
الف مره وفي مره الف مره تسعه ترى النمله
كذا صعود
خذ من النمله والنحله والنخله ثلاثه في
السعاده النمله جرب سعادتك ووظيفتك
وانتاجك الف مره ترى انا شفته بعيني وانت
شفته تصعد وترجع وتصعد في الاخير ترى تصعد
والا تجي من هنا ولا مصره على الصعود يا
اخي جرب وظيفه ثانيه عمل اخر انزل السوق
يا اخي جرب موهبه انما في البيت تقول
مهموم لا اصعد الثاني خذ من النخله
الاستعلاء وانا اوصيك علشان التعليق اللي
قبل شويه النخله سامقه مرتفعه وتاتي برطب
يرمون
والزهور يذهب الى المزبنه ينقر الاذى
وينشر القذى ينقل الاذى وينشر القذر قال
كن فصيله النحل اولها الذباب ناتي بالاخ
هذا نقول تعال يا اخي انت ما حاولت اصلا
ولا لا انت جربت طريقه النمله ولا طريقه
النخله ولا طريقه النحله طيب تقعد في
البيت حتى الله يقول قل سيروا في الارض
يعني ابحث واجتهد وسر سبحان الله يا اخي
اللي جعل الحياه هي كفاح لو جعلها الله
سبحانه تاتي براحه اعطى الاسد فريسته عند
ترى الاسد ما يروح ولا يذهب النهار يفترس
من البقر والجمال ويواجه مصاعب النحلته
كان اعطاها الله سبحانه عندنا ترى تذهب
وانت تعرف ترى عالم مملكه الشغالات شغالات
هنا والعاملات وهي تذهب تاخذ الرحيق وتاتي
به العصفور يقول سبحانه يقول صلى الله
عليه وسلم في السنن لو توكلت على الله حتى
توكلتكم كما
لابد نقدو فاذا قضيت الصرف انتشروا في
الارض نحن نريد ثقافه عند بعض الشباب يا
شيخ يقول لنا حظوظ
قلت كيف حضور ولا حتى اللي جاءهم
الحضور هذا كلمه الشباب العمر بن الخطاب
لانه في المسجد صار لهم بعد صلاه الظهر
واذا قال العصر سبحوه عمر انكر الموضوع
دخل عليهم قال ما انتم قالوا عباد يقولون
عبادهم كان حنا عباده يقول عمر من يطعمكم
يعني الغداء والعشاء والفطور قال جيرانكم
خير انتظروني هو بياخذ الدر هذي اذا ضربها
كافر اسلام يطلع الجن ويحسبونه بيجيب غدا
صك باب المسجد دخل اتيه بدم قال اخرجوا
فان السماء لا تمطر ذهبا ولا فضه يقول
سبحانه فاذا قضيت الصلاه مش هو فانتشروا
في الارض طيب يا ابني روح ابحث طيب
الناجحين ذلحين في وطنا رواد انا دخلت
سعودي وسعودي من الشباب كلهم منتجين مو
رائعين ومقدمين ليش خرجوا وبذر طيب
يمكنك مزارع انت نجحك انت تكون مزارع يمكن
والله لو تبي انه اشرف لك ان تبقى مهموم
مكدودا تنتظر من ابيكم من اخوانك ارسلوني
اعطوني والله اني احترم القهوجي الجرسون
هذا يوم يقدم القهوه
التحيه واقول شكر الله لك وراه اسره كنت
وراهم انه شريف والله اللي يبيع الخضروات
انه في عمل جرير وعظيم ولذلك الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم قدس هذه المهمات وبارك له
واعطتم وبع حطبه وباع واعطاهنا واسرته
فالحياه لا تعترف بالمقصرين يا اخي
الجامدين
الكتاب انه سوف تلقيهم الحياه مثل ما يلقي
النخل النحل النحل في الخليه الميت ترى
الميت من يخرجه خارج الخريه ما هو شغال
ولو عامل ولا ينطلق فالله الله لا تكون
ميتين اسعدوا فان الحياه تحب الاقوياء
والقوه القوه يقول المؤمن القوي خير محب
الى الله من المؤمن الضعيف
بالنسبه للناس اللي عالقين في الماضي يعني
لا اله الا الله تلقى عنده كثير من النعم
الا انه لا يزال يعيد ويكر في مشاكل
الماضي جميل هذه يا شيخ مرض خطير لا يعالج
الا بعقيده الانسان الى درجه عقيده ما
مضافات هذا فصل لا تحزن مضى فات يقول تعال
بالماضي واحبسه في زنزانه الاهمال ولا
تفتحه ابدا الله يقول عفا الله عما سلف
يقول لا تحدث خلاص انت الله لما اتكلم عن
الامم الاخرى قال تلك امه قد خلت لها ما
كسبت ولكم ما كسبت لماذا لماذا تجر الماضي
ولذلك لا تطحن الطحين هنا لا تطحن الطحين
ولا تنشر
كيف يقول تطحن الطحين تاتي بالماضي وتريد
ان تطحن الطحينه مطحون اسرع وتستجر الماضي
تاتي النشار وتنشرها لانه ما مضافاته
المؤمن وغيمون الماضي لا يعيده شيء بل
اتيك بكلمه جانب سعد حتى
عندهم خطير مثل بن خلدون عندنا يقول
التفكر في الماضي حمق وجنون حمق وجنون انا
ارى اني اعيش في الماضي والله لا تستطيع
والله لو تجمع العالم كله تغيير شيء ماضي
ما يتغير كان الحمق والجنون صدق التفكر في
الماكي حمض حمق وجنون فما دام اعرف ان
الماضي هذا مضى ماذا ناخذ الماضي العبره
والعظه حتى لو في خطا في معصيه في شيء
ناخذ العبره ما هي العبره يوم اخطانا وش
الدرس اللي فيها اما اني اقعد اندم وانياح
وصياح حتى العالم حتى الرواد كان لهم
خطايا ولهم اسرافات ووجد فيهم من التاريخ
من صار مبدعا ورائعا وكان له ماضي
على صحتك النفسيه على الحزن انه اثر عليك
الفراغ مدمر يا شيخ الفراغه هو كالسياره
يقول التي تنزل في هدوء في انحدار بلا
بريك بلا فرامل فيتجنح ذات الايميل وذات
الشمال الفراغ
قال اذبح الفراغ بسكين العمل ويضمن لك
اطباء العالم سبعين في المئه من النجاح
والصحه والسعاده الفراغ هي الشيخ هو سبب
كل مشكله في العالم لا ياتي الحاد الا مع
الفراغ والارهاب
الظن والجريمه والمعصيه مع الفرار والتخلص
من الفرج يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم نعمتين
فيهما كثير من الصحه والفرار
فيها كثير من الناس تجدوا لا يتحرك اذا
رايت شاب جالس فارغ اعرف انه مدبر وان
الشيطان دخل معه وسوف لا يشير عليه
الشيطان الا بالاسوء لان ما عنده ماده
يفعلها في هذا الفراغ ولذلك وصي باستثمار
العمل يمكن لو قلت لي ما هو العمل يعني
مثلا الحل للسعاده والحل لترك الهم والحزن
الشغل العمل الشغل انا اظلم مثلا انظروا
العمال الان وقد سبقني حتى اللي كتبوا فيه
العمال الان على السقائل في شده الحر وفي
حرب الرياض خمسين ولا مثله والله يا شيخ
انه يتبسمون ويضحكون وانهم على السقايل
ونمشيدون الطوب والبلوك والسمنت وانهم
اقوياء ويغردونك العصافير وان في شباب في
الغرف والمكيف وشغل عليه وكل المواد عنده
وانه في هم ويتناول عقاقير للكابه هذا
العمل ولذلك العمل
يقول العمل هو قرار قرره حتى الالمان يقول
بعد الحرب قالوا الموت او العمل العمل ثم
العمل ثم العمل يقول نابليون نقلت عنه
المجد لك يحتاج الى ثلاثه امور اسمع المجد
يحتاج الى ثلاثه امور العمل ثم العمل ثم
العمل وصدق وكل العمل ولذلك اللي ما يعمل
سوف يسقط قاطره الحياه لن ترحم يا شيخ حتى
اخوان الانسان
تعتمد عليهم حتى ياتي فتره من فترات يملون
تقول مال لا تصحبنا لا نستطيع ان نصرف
عليك نعطيك فانا اراني شيخ حل العمل
الفراغه ترى يباغه الانسان ولذلك يكون
مستعد من اول انا اعطيك قضيه استعد في
نفسك ترى بيجيك فرغم ضحى ولا بعد العصر
ولا بعد المغرب كان يكون عندك مشاريع
جاهزه وقتيه انا وقت الفراغ لابد ان امشي
لان الرياضه ترى عمل وقت الفرع عندي كتاب
مجهز او انا عندي ورد من القران ودي اتدبر
وخاصه اذا غصت في المعاني ما هي بالتلاوه
المجرده كذا انا ارى انه يكون عنده تفسير
بن سعدي تغوص في مصر لانك اذا دخلت في
الغوص بدا يشتغل ذهنك فيشغلك عن هذيك
الخانات ترى وانا جربت الموضوع خاصه اذا
كان اصعب واصعب يعني مره يجيني ادخل في
كتاب عميق ودي مثل اداره عرض العقل
واتلخبط معنا وياه واتشاكل مع ذاك فرد
فاسرع اشعر بسعاده لاني انا نسيت نفسي لان
الخانه فارغه غطيت بالحزن والكعبه
تتصل بالورنه من تقوم يا شيخ تجلس مع
الاسره او حتى وانا اقترح ترى يكون عندك
اصحاب ولا اربعه مريحين ومتفائلين منجزين
يعني ويكون بينك وبينهم لقاءات ترى يا شيخ
السعاده بشرط يكون منجزين ومتفائلين تجي
بناس متفائلين يضحكون ولكن ما عندهم رساله
في الحياه لا تجيب ناس عندهم رساله لكن
محبطين لا متشائمين متشائم وفارغ هذا
الدمار هذولا الصحبه الطيبه التي تضفي على
الوقت وتطفي على الجهد يكون بينكم برنامج
مسبق ولو بسيط ليس ليس شوف ورقه عمل دائما
كان يصيبها الناس
بمسمى العصر ورقه عمل قبل اللقاء يكون
عندنا مشروع يكون عندنا كلمه نستفيد نقرا
في كتاب نستفيد من وقتنا فباذن الواحد
الاحد انه اني انا احذر من الفراغ المدمر
يا شيخ وما رايت معصيه الا سبقها فرع نعم
سبقها فرع لان الفراغ هذا اتى الشيطان
وحضر وما حضر ذكر الرحمن
وما رايت احدا اقدم على قتل او ارهاب او
فسكن او معصيه الا سبقها فراغ تمكن هذا
الفراغ مع الجهل وعدم الايمان والعلم من
ملء الفراع نعوذ بالله
الثقافه والمعرفه على تخفيف الحزن جدا
سبحان الله يا اخي يقول على حسب المعرفه
اقوى شيء المعرفه هذا كلمه انا معروفه
يعني رسمي يقول احسن ما قال ذكرت هذا
الكلمه المعرفه اقوى شيء ما في مثل العلم
ولذلك فاعلم انه لا اله الا الله اول كلمه
اقرا
ما الله ما امر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يتزوج من شيء لا من جهه ولا منصب ولا فلوس
ولا ربي زدني علما العلم يقول ابن القيم
يوسع صدر الانسان حتى يكون اوسع من
السموات واوسع من السموت يصيغ على حسب علم
الانسان ومعرفه وسيع البطال وسع الرؤيه
وسير العذر والسعر حتى
تجدون الذين يعلمون حتى تجد الانسان مع
الثقافه ومع العلم يحذر الناس وينظر جوانب
الايجابيه وبعيد الغضب ولا يزعل ويفهم
يعني ان مع العسر يسرا عنده الجهل يا شيخ
يضيق الجاهل يا شيخ يغرق في كوما نسال
الله على حسب وتجد يجعله من حب قبه يقول
لي واحد يقول والله بعض المسائل في ناس
يعني كانوا اذا طفت الدينامو في المسجد
سوى قضيه عالميه منطف الدين حسب الرضا
شوفوا القضيه ولذلك تجد بعض الناس يعني
باع في غنم ومن بعث له اشغل الناس قال
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل من اللي اصاب سوق
الغنم مساله الشعير للدوام قضيه كبرى عند
بعضهم ترى ولذلك
وتعظموا في عين الصغير صغارها وتصغر فعلا
العظيم العظيم من واحد الامير اسمه سعود
الله يرحمه في شريط الذكريات اللي كان مع
الشبيني او الشبيلي يقول الملك عبد العزيز
ينطبق عليه هذا البيت وتعظم في عين الصغير
صغارها
وتصغر في عين عظيم العظيم ترى العظيم حتى
من افراد الناس تجد عظيم حتى يقولون
تقولوا مساله تقول ترى فلان اخطاء في الله
يسامحه يا رجال حنا مسهل مشي وتجد ترى
ناقص قال يا رجال الخير بيجي يا رجال صادق
مع العسر يسرا تجيب اشياء قال ترى نقدك
قال ترى يمكن بحسن ظن ترى ما تدري يمكن هو
قصدي يقومنا
وتجد هذا القليل لعله اعوذ بالله يضيق معك
حتى ولا تجد له حل وتحاول تقنعوه لان ما
عنده علم ولذلك انا اشوف اقول الجميع حنا
في طور تجديد وفي طور تطور ورياده اذا لم
ننهض بالعلم فلن ننهض باي سبب اخر سبب ترى
التقدم الغربي يقول في مكانه ليس لان
عندهم عقول غير عقولنا وعيون او شيء هم
يقرؤون ولذلك كان يسب العرب قبل سبعين سنه
العرب لا يقرون معاصرين ولذلك اذا اردنا
الرياده القراءه القراءه باي وسيله حتى
تواصل كتاب الالكتروني كتاب ورقي القراءه
وقل ربي زدني علما اقرا القراءه تجعلك
مطمئنه وتجعلك رائدا ترى يا شيخ الرواد
الناجحين في العالم والعباكر اوسع الناس
صدرا ولذلك كما تعرف والله اني ما اريد ان
الله يعلم بنيه لكن استفدت من بيت يعني
شوف العظمه يقول من الملك عبد العزيز ولا
حسبنا الملوك ولا عيال الملوك يقول يقص
راس الملك يقول صب قهوه يعني بهدوء يعني
العظائم الامور يعني ان عظيم الامور عند
العظماء ما هي بشيء لكن عندنا عند
التافهين يا شيخ تجده يضيق في كل شيء وانا
قصدي استشهادات هذه يا اخواني كبروا
ادمغتكم وريح دماغك وانظر الى
انا اختصر الحسن البصري يقول اجعل الهم
هما واحدا كيف كيف والله اذا جعلت الهم هم
واحدا سهلت كل شيء لقاء الله
بس يوم القيامه اما غيره كله تافه ترى في
كتاب تعرف في جنوب في الامريكان لا تهتم
بالامور كلها توافتين في الغرب بها ترجم
لا ترى الدنيا كلها حتى يقول المتنبي قد
ذقت لذه ايامي وشدته فما حصلت على اصابه
ولا عسلي يقول كل ماضي هذا كل ما نشوف
الشدائد كله كلام فاضي ويقول هون على بصري
ما شك منظره فانما فلتات العين نظرات
العين كالحلم والله الا حلم يا شيخ ولذلك
من عرف الناس استراح يقول من عرف الناس
استرها قال له بنتي ينفعون ولا يضرون
ويعطون كل مشاكل اللي عندك ترى بعد فتره
ترى نسيم منسيه انت لا تكبر دماغك لا تنظر
مشكله ان كل الازمه وان النهايه لا يا
حبيبي ترى امر الله واسع والحمد لله
الحياه بتستمر ترى يقول بعض الناس
الواهمين يظنون ان الحياه لن تستمر الا
بهم وماتوا ودفنوا واستمرت الحياه بشرك
اجمل واحسن واروع ترى فرعون كان يدير
الارض هو فرعون غطس الله في الماء بشرك
قبل صلاه الظهر غطسه في ما هو مثل الضفادع
ويتغدوا الناس في مصر البقيه وشربوا شاي
فما بكت عليهم السمع والارض وما كان منظري
والحمد لله والله لا بكت السماء ولا بكثره
ولا تغير التاريخ فالتاريخ لن يتغير انا
استفدت من دكتور مره كان يعالجني في فرنسا
بيقول لي قال انت تقلق قبل يعني كذا انا
كنت عارف في جنبي قال المشكله لا تضعها في
امعاء
المشكله فيها يقول خلي المشكلات هنا وجيت
عند ابن تيميه يقول لابن القيم قال له
يكون قلبك كالاسفنجه يستشرب المزعجات يعني
مثل مشاكل اسفنج يعني خلها خلك الزجاجه
كذا زجاج قويه تدركها وتردها بقوتها طيب
نقعد الحين نقص طبعا الراتب تتمشكلنا
ودخلناه في قلوبنا ما نجح البنت ما تزوجت
ما حصلنا بيت ما حصلنا طيب ونجمعها
الله يدبر الامر وكلنا الله فوضني الله
سبحانه وتعالى في الدولار مكتوب تقفل له
اني ما رايت في حياتي والذين سبقوني في
الصبح والخير اعرف مني بها كان نقله
النوعيه من الدعاء ادعوني استجب لكم وخاصه
في السجود في اخر الليل في ساعه الاستجابه
الدعاء نقلها نوعيه ولذلك اكثر الانبياء
في صفحه واحده في القنص سوره الانبياء
تحول المستحيل الى ممكن في صفحه واحده وجه
ايوب خلاص 18 سنه من المرض صار العظم
باللحم قال اني مستني الظن وانت ارحم
الرحمن
فكشف ما ابي منظر
بعد يونس بسطرين دخل في ظلمتني ثلاث الحوت
والماء والظلمه الليل خلاص لا اله الا انت
سبحانك اني كنت فاستجبنا له فنجيناهم بس
ما هو وكذلك الانجيل المؤمنين مثله بعده
زكريا خلاص عمره تسعين خلاص بس الحرم
اصابه شيخا كبيرا وامراته عقيل قال
فاستجبنا له فوهبنا له يحيى الدعاء يا شيخ
نقله نوعيه حتى شوفوا الكفار فاذا ركبوا
في البحر في الفلكي دعوه الله مخلصين له
الدين يا اخي فرعون لما ركبك قال امنت انه
لا اله الا الله بني اسرائيل ولذلك علينا
نحسن الظن بربنا وبحول الله ان النتائج
جميله وايجابيه بحول الله ما رايت عظيما
في الاسلام الا متفائلا قرات موسوعه
العظماء والاعلام للذكر كله وكررته القاسم
مشترك بين العظماء والرواد والمبدعين
التفاؤل
التفاؤل ويبشر حتى في عين العاصفه ترى يوم
قال لا تحزن انه معنا ترى في خمسين سيف
محاطه بالغار ترى قال لا تحزن الله معنا
ترى يوم قال عليه الصلاه والسلام جو قالوا
تستنصر لنا ثلاثه وجاء خبابه يقول يا رسول
الله
قال والذي نفسي بيده لا يتمنى الله هذا
الامر حتى يبلغ مبلغ الليل والنهار انا
العبد الضعيف وصلت الى مبلغ لانجو شرق
الصين في يوم 134 جامع واسمه صلى الله
عليه يدوي هناك وصفك ابشرك كان في فرنسا
ونيس ووصلت الى امريكا الشماليه بواحد
وعشرين ولايه اسمه يدوي في كل مدينه وفي
كل حاره وفي كل مكان وهم ممعون له ثلاثه
يقول هذا الكلام يقول وما ارسلناك الا
رحمه للعالمين ورفعنا لك ذكرك ترى محفر
الخندق ترى مربوط على بطن الجوع وترى محاط
بعشره الاف مسلح قال اريد قصوره كسره وسوف
يفتح بعد 25 سنه
فدائما المبدعين
تبسم للحياه بعمر وتبسموا يا بناتي
وتفائلوا والله ان الغد انه المشرق انه
اجمل من اليوم واني يبشركم بمستقبل واني
انا فعلت بعد ما كتبت فعلت هذا في حياتي
واذا ما شاء الله الاحسن والاجمل وكنت انا
افكر انه بيجي احباطات وانه بيجي
التهويمات اثره من الشيطان يا شيخ مدرسه
ابليس يعيدكم الفقره والله
واذا متفائل يعطيها الله سبحانه وتعالى
مثل ما تتوقع تكون يقول في كتاب السر انت
وقعت ان تكون ناجحا فانت صادق سوف تكون
ناجحا وان توقعت ان تكون راسبا او فاشلا
فانت صادق سوف تكون فاشله وبكذا كما تتوقع
انا عند ظن سبحانه وتعالى انا عندي ظن
عبدي بي فليظن بما شاء تظن انه بيعطيك
بينجحك بيوفقك ابشر تظن اعوذ بالله من سنه
ترى ما بيعطينا ترى دائما تعودنا نعوذ
بالله ترى دايم حظي مكسور ابشر لانه هذا
كذا هذا مدرسه عبد الله انهزموا وفشل
مدرسه محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم النجاح
الرياده الفرح في عباره في مرهم العالم
كتابي عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
والاصرار حتى الانتصار ودرجه عبد الله
بردوني ترى هذه جمله في قصيدتي اجمل قصيده
في محمد بن عبد الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
في هذا العصر شاعر اليمن معروف تعرفه يقول
رساله الرسول وشقت الصمت اسمع الكلام هو
اذا جيت مزار قباني يحط عبد الله
البردنيوم ثلاثه قال وشكت الصمت والانسان
وتحملها تحت السكينه من دار الى دار
وهدهدت مكه الصبر والانسان تحميرها تحت
السكن دارتي الى داري وشب طفل الهدم
المحبوب متشحا بالصبر متشحا بالنور والنار
في كفي شعله تهدي وفي دم عقيده تتحدى كل
جباري وفي ملامحه وعدته يطوي في اعصارا
بعصاره هذا هو الهمه يا شيخ وهذا الرياده
والتفاؤل ولذلك يقول لي غير للذين لا
يتفائلوا ولا يصمدون عنده صبر انتهى الله
يحسن عزاكم في الحياه انتم صرتم عيب على
الحياه وعيب على انفسكم تعالوا الى عالم
السعاده عالم التفاؤل عالم الرضا والله ان
الله عنده يا شيخ الكنوز كلها ولذلك اذا
كان هذول اللي الفوا الغربيين كتاب السنه
حتى كتبت فيه الشرق الاوسط مكانه ثم
نقضتها لانه اول مره فهمت انه يريد ان
يجعل قضب والقدر فعل الانسان او التكتشفت
بعدين فاعتذرت مكانه ثانيه قلت لا هو يريد
الحديث النبوي يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال الله تعالى انا عند ظن عبدي بي يقول
في كتابه يقول اطلب فان الخزائن لا تنتهي
سبحانه هذا يؤمن بالغربيا اطلب فان خزائنه
لكن تبغى العلم ترى عنده تبغى النجاح ترى
عنده الرياده عنده القبول عنده بس انك
تطلب والذين جهدوا فينا لنهدينه وان الله
لمع المحسنين
طيب القضاء والقدر قد يكون احيانا مصيبه
عند الناس كيف يتعامل معها الفقر
فقد ولد بنت
مرض ورائع هذا فضل العلماء الان وفضل
العارفين على العامه عند المسائل هذه لابد
يدرس القضاء والقدر بالنسبه للانسان ليس
في غيبياتي هو يعني اولا في الاسلام موجود
ولذلك وجدنا الحل عنده في ان تؤمن بانه
مكتوب عليك من الله لا يمكن ان يصرف ابدا
ما مصيبه في الارض ولكن الا في كتابه من
قبل ما نستطيع الشيخ ما نستطيع مكتوب عليه
يقول الكاتب اللي نقل عن ذلك يقول كان في
يدي خاتما في صبيع خاتما وكنت في نيويورك
فنسب المسمار في الخاتم فقفزت انا للرياضه
فذهبت اصبعي هذا وعلمت ان هذا مكتوب
فاستمررت والله وشعرت بعدا ما عندي الا ما
نقص عندي اصبع اصلا هذا مثل
قصدي اول الايمان بالقضاء والقدر الثاني
التسليم بالاختيار اختيار الله سبحانه
وتعالى اليس الله يختار لنا وعسى ان تكون
وهو خير لكم عشان تحبوا شيئا لابد
الاستسلام الاختيار لان حنا ما ينظر للبعد
ما نعرف اسرار الامور يمكن اختيارنا وقع
ترى ابنك الذي مات في ميزان حسناته يمكن
له عاش دمرت الدنيا تعرف انت ابن يعني
موسى عليه السلام لما الخضر قتل الغلام
كانوا في المصلحه يا شيخ ما تدري تبكي انت
تقول يا ليت انا وفقنا في الزواج ولدنا من
فلانه ما تدري يمكن هذا النسب انه بيدمر
العائله كلها فهو اختيار الثالث يقول انظر
الى نتائج او ثمار الثمار عند الله عز وجل
هذا الاجر مبشر الصابرين الذين اذا
اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون
قال عمر نعمل عدلان والعلاوه العذران على
الجمال يحطون هنا وعدل والعلاوه فوق اولئك
عليهم صلواتهم ربي ما يرحم عليكم مهتدون
الامر انه قد صرف عنك شيء يمكن اكبر الحان
تحمد الله انه ما في دينك وان كان في دينك
في توبه ومنها يا شيخ انه بيني وبينك انه
والله انه ما ندري احيانا هل الفقر احسن
ولا الغناء ليش وجدنا من اقتنى فدمر دينه
وسعادته وذهب بغناء الى الهاويه يعني يوجد
ناس اعطاهم الله غنى فذهبوا الى مناحي
اخرى حتى ضرت بالدين والوطن وبانفسهم
وجدنا من عاش فقيرا ولكنه مستكنا متواضعا
ولك يا رب ما نقصي عنده كان ياكل خبز ورق
يا رب سبحانه وتعالى فلابد نحل المشكله
بالايمان بالقضاء والقدر وما في شوف الا
الرضا اذا ما رضينا سوف ندخل في متاهات
امران اقول لهم لدعاه الالحاد
يقول لا تظني وصلت يوم نائب رئيس
الجمهوريه كل وقت تم كتب سير الامام ثم
رئيس الجمهوريه قال انا
اتتني صعوبات في حياتي منها اني كنت في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه شاركت في حرب
اليابان وكان عمري 24 سنه فسقطوا الطائره
شوف اسقطها اليمني فوقعت عندي مسدس ولما
خرجت من الماء واذا بياباني اكبر فاخرجت
مسدس وقتل جاب المنضاد ثم قال وقائد البحر
اسمه ميلر امريكي ما كذا تحت الماء في بحث
13 يوم لكن عندهم
خرج ماذا قال قال بعد 13 يوم اكون للعالم
عندي تجربه من عنده خبز وماء من عنده خبز
وماء وصحه فقد ملك العالم
هذا ملخص ترى لا تحزن ولذلك الخبز بن فارس
اللغوي المشير المشي خبز وماء وظل ذاك
النعيم والاجل كفرت نعمه ربي ان قلت اني
ولذلك خصص من اصبح امنا في السرب فسر
الغرفه معافى في بدنه عند وقوته عندك خبز
فكانما سيقت له الدنيا بحذافيره اسالكم
بالله تجاره العالمين اللي عندهم هل يكون
اكثر منا انا واياك بعمر اكلنا اليوم ثلاث
وجبات يمكن باقي عشرة
الامر الثاني انت هو لبس والتجار عشره
ثياب ولبسوا مثله ينظرون وننظر وياكلون
اكل وبعدين فهو مساله كفاف ترى ومساله
تعبير وهي كلها تمشي الى ان نلقى الله
سبحانه وتعالى والله يقول المتنبي يموت
راعي الضان في ضانه
ميته تجاهل ونصف طبيه مشهوره خطير يقول
فيها لو فكر العاشق في منتهى حسن الذي
يسبيه لم يسبيه ابتكه في العبقريه في هذه
المساله يقول ابن تيميه لا يوصف الله بانه
عاشق سبحانه معشوق جنه في علاه ليش لان
العشق ينتهي الفساد الحين شوف اللي يعشقون
الشباب يعشق امه او شيء ترى يتوهم كذا
خيالات انه تختلف وان حوريه جت من الجنه
وكل وهم قال في يقول متنبي نوف لو فكر
العاشق وفي منتهى حسن الذي يشبه لم يسبي
ثم يقول يموت راعي الظال في ضانه ميته
الطبيب اليوناني المشهور هو عاش هناك
الخبز مات ثم ماذا نسعد من ذلك فقضيه
السعاده لا نجعلها بالاشياء والذوات لانه
المنتخبات سوف تنتهي لكن سعادتك انت في
اطمئنانك في رضاك في راحتك في امنك ولا
يمنحها الا الله انا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب والله يا شيخ ان اني رايت انا
الحلول نقرات كتب كثيره ومذكرات غربيه
وكتب مترجمه واني رايت في الاخير حتى
كبارهم يعودون الى الله واذا فاذا ركبوا
الفرك قل اف الله نخاطب العلماء يقول الله
شك من يمنح السعاده ولو وجدت في كلمات هذا
فكيف بالقران الذي دعانا الى الاعتصام به
سبحانه وتعالى
واقول تفائلوا
واطمئنوا ترى غرس البسمه في الدخول في
البيت من اعظم السعادات تقول عائشه في
مسلم قالوا له كيف يدخل عليكم قالت يدخل
ضحاكم بساما دخل كرم ترى هو كان هو اللي
يدير الاصول العرب النبوه الرساله الوعد
المعارك الغزوات المجانيه المال العام
الاداره القوات القتل كل شيء يدخل خلاص
يعني بيدخل بالمشاكل داخل البيت يقول لكم
مشاكلك عند الباب ولذلك دخلت الى صوتك لا
تخبرهم بالجدل مع الزملاء والمشكلات وما
جاء من صدمات ولا كمامات وما عندك من ديون
وهموم لا تضحكن بس
دخلت محاكم بساما عبد الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالسرور في البيت والبسمه والرضا وهي اول
شوف الكتاب يعرف من عنوانه اول ما يدخل
الانسان يترك البسمه تعال بدعاء بين الاهل
وزن اختي الزوجه علينا تبادل زوجها ما
تقابله يقول بعضهم تجمع المشكلات في قائمه
اذا دخلت انت قالت انا فرصه نجتمعنا هذا
فرصه
اولا نبغى انا الثلاجه ما فيها شيء وترى
الفواتير انتهت وراتب الخدامه وترى
السياره بنغير
يعني تجب على الايام لكن الجلسه الاولى ان
تكون مبادره لان انا احب المتفائلين
متبسمين
يعني وانت تتكلم على هذه النقطه احس انها
مره مهم اللي هو استشعار النعم يعني
قديش اليوم احنا نعيش يعني نعم لا يعلم
بها الا الله يعني
اليوم اعيش اكثر يعني اي احد انه يعيش
افضل من ملك ملوك العالم في قبل 300 سنه
تقدر تطلب المويه بارده تجيك بارده في اي
وقت في اي يعني ضغطه زر تطلب الحين اللي
تبغى يعني يوصلك خلال دقائق يعني الاكل
حار وتزعل مو بانها يعني كذا قلنا تاخر
خمس دقائق
فكثره النعم اللي حولك احس الاستشعار فيها
مهم جدا نحن ضعيفين في الشكر يا شيخ ما
وجدت عجزا عند البشريه والناس مثل ضعف
الشكر سبحانه وتعالى في القران من عباده
الشكر
يعرفون نعمه الله ثم ينكرونها اكثر الناس
لا يشكر والله انك تجد الواحد غني وبطران
وان المواعيد قدامه وانه سبعين نوع قدام
ونسرب وكيف حالكم بسم الله ولا الحمد لله
قالوا نعم الله قال يا رجال الخير الحمد
لله انفتح على العالم بخير طيب علمنا
بالسالفه ولا عنده مستشعر انه المنعم الله
سبحانه وتعالى ولا يدري فين كان يا شيخ
نحن لو كان في انا في التاريخ عصر ذهبي
لاني انا قلت
اي واحد في الرياض الان بسيط ترى يعيش
اكثر في الوسائل من هارون الرشيد اللي قال
الغامان
رشيد يقوم في الفجر يجون الخدام يدفون له
مويه ترى في حق النحاس هذا ويجيب المغرفه
علشان بيتروش ويجيب الاكل في الماعون ونحن
بازرار يا شيخ حسين الحياه طيب انت تذكر
انا طبعا اكبر انا يا اخي وانا طفل في
الجنوب والله يا ابا عمر انه ما يجينا
الاشياء والقوت وان نفرح بالعزيمه في
القريه ولا عندنا اضاءه ولا كهرباء ولا
سياره انا اول مره سياره في حياتي وانا
طفل وخرجنا كلنا في مهرجان فزع اهل القرى
كل مجتمع حتى يشوفنا سياره لوري واحد اسمه
حمود لكن صار حدث عالمي مثل الحرب
العالميه والناظر فيها كذا وحتى ريحه
السياره البنزين ان يشمها كانه يا شيخ شيء
كانها ايش ورد يعني لا سمين وتذكر
قبل الابتساح بعضنا والله رايت ناس من
جماعتهم الغنم ويضحكون
لا لكن وجدت نعم الان الثلاجه ممتريه بزر
يا شيخ حار بزر بارد تقترح الان كل مطاعم
العالم عندك في الرياض كان دعوه ابراهيم
يجب الي ثمره كل شيء طيب وين الشكر وين
الحمد يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم في مسلم ان
الله يرضى عن العبد ياكل الاكله فيحمده
عليه يرضى الله تاكل انت مهم من الله من
فضل الله عز وجل قال يعرفون نعمه الله ثم
ينكرون عباد اكثر والله ما يشكر يا شيخ
ولذلك يشربون النعم ويجي عليهم قدرات من
الهم والغم والقلق انا عشت مع الشيخ بن
باز والشيخ عبد الربيع يوسف حاكم ابها
سبحان الله الحمد لله يقول بسم الله الحمد
لله الحمد وياكل باستمرار باستمرار يقول
له عشيري قال المكان
يعني
من اهل القرى عزم بيوسف وهذه الحمد لله
الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله ياكل قال
يشبع تعرفهم يستخدمون لم قد يشبع يعني ما
باقي شبع يظن هو انك لابد تشبع وبعدين
نقول الحمد لله فقضيه انك لو حتى لو حميدا
الله يقول سبحان الله سبحان من لو سجدنا
بالجباه له على سفر والمحمي من الابر لم
نبلغ العسر من مقدار طاعته والعسر وعشره
من العشرين والله يا شيخ لو سجدنا سجده
واحد العمر ما بلغنا هذه النعم شيخه يقول
تصور انت يقول يود الاعمى انه يملك عينين
بالدنيا وما فيها والله نعمل الان في
مدرسه النور في المستشفى وتقول يا ابني او
يا اخي قال انا ابشرك بيردون لك العينين
قالوا الحقيقه وتشوف العالم
وتخيلوا في الارض كلها في الدنيا يختار
العينين والاصم يا شيخ واللي يمشي واللي
عنده انا اقرا قريب الواحد دكتوره زغلول
النجار يعني يقدم يقول ان فيك شركات في
الجسم شغاله من اجلك جعلها الله سبحانه
وتعالى شركه الجزء القلب هذا الشيء انا
جلست عند بعض الاطباء الاطباء القلب في
المستشفى التخصصي الملك فيصل التخصصي واذا
القلب عام عمل ثاني شيخ هو التخصصات وشيء
طبيب العيون ايضا في الدكتور عبد الله
عسيري في مستشفى الملك خالد العيون اثار
العيون كما تعرف الشبكيه والقرنيه واشياء
شركات متخصصه الله اعطاك اياها ومنحك اياه
سبحانه الكبد الطحال كل ما في جسمك يقول
وفي انفسكم افلا تبصرون طيب فكر في نفسك
انت هذا النعم ونحن منعموني الشيخ لكن
قليل الشكر يا شيخ قليل والله قليل سواء
لان الشكر بالقلب تعتقد انه منعم وحده
باللسان الحمد لله وتذكر عند المحبين وما
من عند ربه حتى مع اهلك انا وجدت من اروع
الوجبات في الدروس انك اذا جلست معها لك
انك تستغل الفرصه لا تترك لهم مجال يجون
بالسلبيات في النقص يقول والله اليوم ما
شاء الله تبارك الله تفكرت ما شاء الله
انه سكنا في الفيلا هذي والله اني تفكرت
ناس كثير وان حصلت ناس ما عندهم مساكين
وناس ما عندهم بيوت وناس بتدخل في الموضوع
نعمه مثلا ما شاء الله تبقى اولادنا سينما
من الاعاقه والله ان الاعاقه صعبه وان كذا
وتذكر هذا فتاتي تستولي على المجلس
بالسعاده لانه بيجي الاحباط بعدين
وينبغي يا اخي ان نفكر في المقابل انك ترى
الذي مطرك يعني سيتمشى في الدنيا ويرى
ويبصر ترى اناس حرموا هذه اللذه وحرموا
نعمه البصر ومنهم منحرم من نعمه السمع
وغير ذلك من النعم فنسال الله ان يوزعنا
الشكر ولذلك يبغى يقول اللهم اعني على ذكر
على ذكرك وشكرك وحسن عبادتك سبحان الله
الذي جعل الزياده في النعم مع الشكر
ويتاذن ربكم لان شكرتم لاجئنا سبحان الله
والله الشيخ شوف من الناس حتى يقول زهير
بن ابي سلمى والكفر مخبثه لنفس المطعم
يعني المنعم المنعم يكمل الدنيا من الناس
اذا اعطاك البعيد وما شكره البيت ترى
ينقلب يقول وش هذا اعطيته ولا شكر ساعدته
في الزواج ما شكر قام في سلفت وما شكر كيف
برب العالمين يقول ان شكرتم منين كفرتم
الشكر مذنب بالزياده ولذلك يعني يعلم الله
انك تستاهل فينمنحك ويزيدك وما شكر انسان
في مشروع او برنامج او خطه الا اعطاه الله
نجاحا الى نجاح وله الحمد حتى يرضى ولذلك
الحمد لله تمر الميزان شوفوا يا اخي الحمد
لله سبحان الله الذي انعم والله ليس من
ذكائنا يا شيخ وليس من تخطيطنا
تجد بعض الناس خرج من قريه فقيرا مبهذلا
معدما وصار نجما لامعا بفضل الله عز وجل
وترى قضيه الشكر رائعه يعني تستصحب
الناجحين كثيرا يا اخي رايت في حياتي ناس
ناجحين الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
اللهم لك الحمد اللهم لك الحمد وزياده
وزياده وزياده والكنود هذاك يسلم بالنسبه
للاحزان احس احيانا انها تعطي الانسان
فرصه انه
اتذكر يعني وحده من مرتيات الرائعه اللي
هي حقت ابو الحسن التهامي في ولد ودي
تحاكيني عن الابداعات اللي جاءت بذر الحزن
يا سلام هذا خصصت له الدراسه وفصل جذب
التهامي والمتنبي وغيره يقول ربما تكون
الصدمه هي طريق النجاح في حياتك لا الازمه
هذه قد تقوي كلمات تقتلك تقويك وحتى اللي
تقتل تذهب الى الله لكن يا شيخ سبحان الله
العظماء رايت الصدمات في حياتهم كانها هي
لبعتهم وقوتهم يعني لو لم يمت ابن الحسن
التهامي وهو طفل ومحبوب عنده ما ترك لنا
قصيده الراعي الخالد هذه يقول حكم البنيه
في البريه جاري ما هذه الدنيا بذلك الى ان
يقول طبعت على كادري وانت تريدها
صوف من اقدار ومكلف الايام غير اتباعهم
متطلبا في الماء جدوى ناري الى ان يقول يا
كوكبا ما كان اكثر عمري وكذا تكون كواكب
الاسحار
يقول دار متى ما اضحكت في يوم ابقى ابكت
غدا لكن رائعه ومنتجه جت من قلب دين الشيخ
شوف الاعمال التي تاتي من معاناه هي حتى
يقول مثلا بيقول لا تعدل مشتاق في اشواقي
حتى يكون حشاك في احشائي اذا ما جئت من
قلب ما خرجت ما تيجي يقول فارقين على كرسي
جسدا اللي ينظم قصيده بارد كذا تحترم كيف
اكله وجبه مندي واخذ ينظم من معاناه وما
بصح معانا اصلا تجد ولا تذهب ولذلك
المتنبي قلت الاصابه الحمى عصابه الحمى
ترى بيرجع من مصر وعطلته في بيت الحمى الى
الصباح قالوا جزاه الله خير الحمى اللي
طلعتنا يقول وزائرتي كان بها حيان فليس
تزور الا فضل من المغرب يا اخي جاب
ابداعات فيها يقول فيها وانف من اخي لابي
وامي اذا ما لم اجدهم من الكرامي الى ان
يقول ولم ارى في عيوب الناس عيبا كنقص
القادرين على التمام هذا البيت خالد من
البيوت الخالده جاب الحمى بسبب الحمى
معاناه ولم ارى في عيوب الناس عيبا كنقص
قادرين على التمام ما في اكثر شيء من
انسان شاب او شابه بيكون احسن وهو باحسن
وبيكون اكثر ابداع ولا يصير يكون اكثر
ابداع الرئيس الفرنسي كتب امر بكتابه هذا
البيت بعد ما ترجم على الدبابات الفرنسيه
بنبيدو هذا تعرف هو قبل بعد
زار الملك فيصل وبعدين ما تبي الترهل كان
يقرا مثقف ترجمه
ولم ارى في عيوب الناس عيب كنا قادرين على
التمام ابيض
معاناه ابن تيميه لما دخل ترو في السجن
اخذ يكتب ويؤلف لانه يخاف عنه ابدع
وكثير يا شيخ رايتهم انا انما ابدعوا
لانهم اتتهم مصيبه مثلا يا شيخ ابو ذئب
الهذري خمسه ابناء قيل سبعه من الطاعون
اتى بصرخه موجعه في قصيده تسمى يقول عدد
منطاوي اذا ذكرنا الروائع والخالدات في
السن نذكر هذه اللي يقول
وتجلده للشامتين اريهم اني غيب الدهر لا
اتضاضع حتى كاني الحوادث مروه بصفر مشقر
كل يوم تقرا الى اخر ذلك يعني من الصبر
ومن العظمه منها ذكرت انا بعضه فيها مالك
ابن الريب في نفسه ترى دنت على الوفاه انا
اجود مره نفسه ومالك ابن الريب اللي يقول
اللي يقولون لا تبعد وهم يدفنونني واين
مكان البعد الا مكانيه فيا ريت تشعرها ان
ابيتن ليله بواد
حتى عضد الدولي امر بقتل بنقول والله اني
ودتني وقتلت وسربت وقيله في القصيده جاهوا
قبل جثمان والناس يبكون والنساء كان يصرف
عليهم وينفق عليهم ويعطي ويعطي الايتام
نفسهم ومقتول قال علوم في الحياه وفي
المماتي لحقه انت احدى المعجزات كان الناس
حولك حين قاموا وفودنا ذاك ايام الصلاه
كانك واقف فيهم خطيبا وهم وقفوا قيام
للصلاه يوقف صليب على المنبر مدته ما شاء
الله ترحب بالمسامير ميت مددت يديك نحوهم
واحتفان تمدهم اليهم بالهبات ولما ضاق بطن
الارض عن انوار في تلك المكرمه اصاروا
الجو قبرك واستعاظموا عن الاثواء عن
الاثواب ثوب السافياتي اثوب ومارك تربه
فاقول لانك نصبه هطلاتي قال ما شاء الله
وحارسينك حتى لا تسكن عشان ينزلون
وحولك قالوا وحولك الحره تبغى كان بسرعه
بحراسه وتصبح وتبي ترعى بحراسه وحفاظ
ثقاته وتوقدوا حولك النيران ليلا كذلك
كذلك كنت اياما حياتي ركبت مطيه الصلب
الجذع هذا قال ما عرفت العظماء يركبون هذه
المطيه هذي معروف المنبر ترى المنبر كبير
ركبت مطيه من قبل زيد عليها في السن
الخاليه زيد بن حسن صلوبه هشام بن عبد
الملك يقول ترى بطل قال سامحني على
التقصير ابكى الناس وابكى الحضور ولو ان
استطعت قيامه حقي علينا بالحقوق الباقيات
الواجباتي ملات الارض من نظم القوافي ونحت
بها خلاف الناحيه عليك تحيه الرحمن تغدو
بتبريك رواد سارياتي وكنت تجيرنا من جور
الدهر فاصبح طالب لك بالتراتي يقول فين
نذهب فبكى الناس ثم شرد الى حلب فاعطوا
القصيده على الدور اللي امر بقتل الملك
فقرها فساد الدموع
قال والله اني ولدت اني قتلت قيلتي
شوف يا شيخ الماساه محمد بن حميد الطوسي
القائد العباسي محمد ترى بطل يمكن ما مر
في العباسيين اكثر بطوله من في عهد معتصم
تقدم الى الروم جهاد
قاتل بتسعه اسياف تكسرت في بطل قوي وفصل
اصلا انكسرت السيوف ثم ضرب بالرماح وقتل
حملوه على النعش ويمدروا المعتصم انه
بيدخل قائد هو انكسر من قتل شهيد فخرج
النساء على اصلحه المنازل والبكاء والنساء
وخرجوا وخرج المعتصم عشان
اصبح احمر واذا هو بالدماء مدرج بغداد
تحولت الى مناحه شهيد قام ابو تمام قال
كذا فريق الخطبه ليفضح الامر فليس بعين لم
يفضماه عمره عذروا توفيت الامان بعد محمد
محمد محفظه واصبح في شغل عن السفر السفر
فتن كلما فاضت عينه قبيله عندما ضحكتان
احاديث والذكر ترد ثياب الموت حمرا فما
دجل لها الليل الا وهو من سنه عليك السلام
الله وقفا فانني رايت بكريم الحر ليس له
عذر وليس عذر وما مات حتى ماتضربوا سيفي
من الضرب واعتلت على اركان السمرو الى
اثبت في مستنقع الهولن ما فر فاثبت في
مستنقع اله
[موسيقى]
وهو معذب حتى يقول هو في قصرتي يقول وعذلت
اهل العشق حتى ذقتوا هذا معانا فعجبت كيف
يموت من لا يعشقه وعذرتهم وعرفت ذنبي انني
عجرت انفرقت في المعاناه دائما صعبه ولكن
نتائجها دائم سليمه الرجل العادي البسيط
التقليدي سوف يمر مع التاريخ يعني يمشي مع
الناس كثيرا لكن الذين يريد ان يكون لهم
ارقام لا بدي اقول لهم توضحيات ولهم وقفه
ولهم عطاء ولهم شيء يقول الذهبي يذكر بعض
المبدعين ترجم كاني طولت بعض المبدعين في
ارقامهم يشوفها ابو الطاهر السلفي محدث
كبير فيقولون الشباب بعدين قالوا ما شاء
الله يا امام كيف بلغت الناس يسلمون على
يدك ويسلمون على راسك صار امام الدنيا ابو
الطير السنفي قال والله الذي لا اله الا
هو انني مكثت في مناره الاسكندريه سبعين
سنه اني ما تزوجت ولا تاهت ولا طرشت اطلب
العلم صار عالم الدنيا كلها بسبعين سنه
الامام التابعين قال الذهبي بكت بنت
وفاطمه عند في سكره
والله ما فاتتني تكبير ستين سنه في المسجد
وكان هو معلم المسجد ومدرس ومعلم المعاناه
عطاء بن ابي رباح ترى انت تعرف سيرته
واعطانا نبي ربح الهمه ولذلك الذين يشغلون
الناس بشجارات الانساب ويهددون الناس
قال ابشرك ان من الافلام وفخذ ال فلان
وترى اخواني
لا عنده ابداع
فين ابداعك اذا فخرت بابائهم نعم صدقت
ولكن باسمه فين انت انت علمني وش بينفعك
الرميم في القبر طلعنا عظام وتقول بجدي
وبس جدك وش سويت انت في عطاف النبي
امراه من مكه من امراه سيده يشتغل عندها
تقول اعطني حطب يسحب حطب مكسر ما هو صحيح
قال تعجن العجين قال اسقطه في الفرن مسكين
احول افطس افطس كان اعرج
جاء من الحبشه يعني مثل ضعيف قالت لهم شوف
انا بعتقد وجه الله والله اتخلص منك
لكن انت لا تصلح للنساء وخلال الخطاب ولا
الخبز ولا شيء قال فماذا قالت تذهب اطلب
العلم الله شاك شوف معانا اطلب العلم
قالوا والله اني جلسته بفراشي ثلاثين سنه
في الحرم ما خرجت 30 سنه يسمع بن عباس
ويسمع العلماء ولا بن عمر ويحفظ وسمع
التفسير كله وسمع حديث
صار عالم مكه وعالم الدنيا حاجز سينما بن
عبد الملك الخليفه اللي يحكم ثنتين عشرين
دوله فقال اختلفوا في مساله طواف مع السعي
قال فين بعطاء نبي ربح عالم الدنيا قالوا
كبر عاد مثل النسر منحني بوافطه سوا واسمر
والاستماره اجمل ترى
واحنف وله كذا قال هذا عطاء قالوا عطاء
قالوا هيبه قالوا طيب بتقدم هو خليفه ذاك
الوقت ومعه العسكر ومعه الوزراء والامراء
والناس
قال ابغى اتكلم قال خذ اشتراك مع الناس
خليفه قالوا سليمان مع الناس جانا سليمان
يوم جلست على حده اتى السره ساله فافتاه
او دخل ابناءه سليمان عن حدا قال يطلبون
العلم والله الذي نفسي بيده ما اذلني احد
في هذا الاشياء الافطس قال الشاعر كان
حاضر الشاعر سليمان قال يابس سؤال فلا
يراجعه هيبه والسائلون نواقص الاذكاني ادب
الوقار وعزه سلطان التقى فهو المطاع وليس
لها سلطان ليش ثلاثين سنه معاناه اخذ
وعطاء وجهد يا اخي انا وجهت تجار سعوديين
وغير سعوديين والله تاجر في حفر الباطل
والله يغفر اسمه عثمان بن ماضي يسمعوني
اهل والله يغفر له هو من حرمه اصلا
وعشينا خروف ويتصدق وينفق
ونقليات في الحبوب قالت تظن ان هذا
التجاره من حصلته كذا يعني هديه قال والله
اني في شبابي اني اخذ الغنم امشي مشي الى
الكويت وانه جاء مره مطر ان استحوذ المطر
تحت شجره يظلم
انتفض الى الصبح انقذوني
كل المعاناه حتى وصل الى هذا فقضي بعض
الاخوه يظنون المجد انهم سهل وان الرياده
سهله هذه لابد من معانا ولابد من صبر
ولابد من عطاء والله لا يخيب لا يخيب من
قصد سبحانه والله انك سوف تجد ثمر امامك
ركبت مع صاحب تاكسي مطيري الله يمسيك
بالخير
من جده الى مكه قال شوف هاي شوف عمي ارسم
هدفك هناك وتوجهنا والله ما يخيبك الله
ولا انا عند ظن عبدي عبدي بي انا اظن عند
عبدي
كنت وانا صغير اقول يعني احسن شيء انا اظن
في انا صغير انك الخطيب هذا والوعظ اكبر
شيء في الحياه كنت متعلق القي كلمه جيت في
مجالي واني اعرف ناس من كان يخطط يكون
مهندس وصار مهندس باذن الله وبحولكم منهم
مسار ضابط وضابط ناجح منهم من سار تاجر
والله صار تاجر لان الله سبحانه وتعالى ما
يخيب يا شيخ يبغى همه صبر ويكون في عطاء
ويكون في بذل وفي تضحيه وايش يا اخي ترى
منمر به في التاريخ اشياء انا وقفته
مذهولا من صبرهم تدري الامام احمد انه
خمسين سنه يطوف الدنيا يقول الذهب يشوف
العهده اكرمكم الله حذاءه باقي 17 سنه
يركع ابو عبد الله الجماعه ما عنده شيء
شيخ ترى عنده قرصان يابسه راحه
صار امامها
العباسيه حتى انه وقف للدرع بس
الصف الاول يطلب الحديث حتى ترك لنا
المسند المسند بالمكرر اربعين الف حديث
الان طبع احسن طبعه خمسين مجلدا وصار في
العالم انا رحت اندونيسيا مسجد احمد بن
حنبل الصين مسجد احمد بن محمد
ليش لانه امام البخاري انا اشوف فيديو امس
ترى سجنه ثلاثه
تعرض له وارني صبور وبخاراء
وسمرقند تعرضوا المخرجه في كل ما دخل
راعهم وبقيوا
من اشهر الناس بعد الصحابه الان في كل في
العالم سواء هاجموني يا اخي عمل انساني
رهيب حتى يقول ملحم من القصيم الدكتور في
الجامعه الامام قال قدم عالم عالم علم ايش
قدم انجازا انسانيا تفخر به الانسانيه
البخاري بماذا لانه يا اخي بذل ضحى يقول
يبيض الصحيح كان ما بينت ما كتبته حديثا
بعد ما جمع الا صليت توضات وصليت ركعتين
واستخرت الله وكتبته في روضه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بيضه في 16 سنه
ولذلك انظروا الان الابداع ان نقدم وثيقه
فانا اقول يا حبيبنا الاعمال الخالده لن
تدفن وعلى الانسان لا يعتمد على العظام
مساله يكون عظامي واجدادي ولن ينفعوا شيء
والله انه وجدنا يا شيخ ناس ليس ما تعلقوا
بنسب ولا شيء وان مسار الرواد ويسلم عليهم
الكبار على روسيا وان راينا ناس من اسر
وجمعوا شجره الانساب عندهم مخطوطات وان
الواحد منهم ما يقود ما يسد في عنز والعنز
اغلى منه ثمنا ومشغل الناس لا هي همم يا
حبيبي وتوقد ترى المتنبي تعرفه ما هو بذاك
اللي جاب اسره كذا جاب طموح وجاب ابداع
برياده وجاب حتى صار
مشاعر في اليمن يمدح المتوكل حاكمهم ملكهم
فكانوا اعجبته نفسه قال مالكم والله نتمنى
اشعر الشعراء قالوا ابشرك اني اشعر
المتنبي قال كذبت وكذب ابوك وكذب جدك انا
في برنامجك يا حبيبي ما احد الفضاء بدون
اسماء الذي احبه من قلبي احد الفضلاء
استضفته انت يقول
شوقي اشعر متربي وانا اقول قبله على حبيبي
هذا الذي يحب يحبني والله بقوله يا بيت
المتنبي بيت واحد انه اشهر من شوقي
واخواني وابنائي وعماتي وخالاتي وجداته
وجدتي وقرابته وجيرانه
ويا المتنبي انني انا مفتول انا مجنون
متنبي انا عشت معه 35 سنه وانه يقول
الشوكاني يقول الشوكاني
المتنبي له 300 بيت تدور يقول المحاكم
اليمن قال كذبت وكذبوك وجدك للشعر والبعيد
له 300 بيت تدور على السنه الملك فضل عنه
حفظتها كذا والله اني جاء واحد صاحب قناه
في لندن بدون اسماء في الجنادريه قال يا
عايض انا ابغى نروح عند الملك سلمان امير
الرياض نسلم عليه الامير سلمان ملك سلمان
كان امير رياض يستقبل ناس عشاء يوم
الاثنين فحضرتك
فتعرف انا مفتوح في المتنبي قال الملك
سلمان لذاك كيف احوالكم يا فلان قال والله
مره تعجبك يا طويل العمر
واني رحت مسؤول كبير الى واحد مشايخ عنده
قال حنا وياك يقول المسؤول مثل ما يقول
متنبي ومنكد الدنيا على الحر ان يرى عدوا
لهم ما صدقت يبدو حاضر معنا يا شيخ وحاضر
مع الرساله بن باز جلسنا في مجلس مره يرد
على لوحه كانه تثاقل
كانت تلفون ثابت فنزل
اذا شاء في لهجه اذا سعى في عمر سعى ظنونه
وصدق ما يعتاد وانت هذا البيت اشهر من
شوقي وخالاته وعماته وخواته من
الرضاعه انا ما اسمع في المتنبي انا باموت
جيني سكته قلبيه انت
خاف الله فيها ابو عمر
لا يا حبيبي انا يعني انا
يلاقيني في بطن الوادي انا يا اخي مقدم
نفسي شوف انا لا اسمع فيه ثلاث الصلاه في
وقتها وبنتين احترافه والاستشهاد بسعر
المتنبي ولا شيء اصول هذه متنبي ما تدري
يا شيخ القصيبي راسلتهم برساله الله يرحمه
وقلتها مع الاستاذ غيره فرد علي قال
وعليكم السلام واعجبني كتابك في المتنبي
لكن
ارسل لي كتاب له في المتنبي في استشهاداته
وكيف انه بقع في الدنيا صار عالمي يقول
الذهبي على مسؤوليتي وراجعوا كلام الذهبي
يقول لا يوجد في العالم اشعر من المتنبي
في الدنيا اما مثله فقليل
في الدنيا اما مثلك طيب من الشيطانك الان
اسالهم يعني
حتى يقول يقول شوف يا اخي يقول اذا غامرته
في شرف مروء فلا تقنع بما دون النجوم طيب
اعطيني شوقي ما يحفظ
لاني انا اريد الحقيقه معناه ان هذا اخي
فاضل الحبيب الشيخ الجليل ترى احبه واسع
الدائره في المعرفه وفي الادب وفي كل شيء
لكن مهما كان بالحمد يعني
انت حجبت انا مثله ما يخفى عليه انه لبيب
ولغوي مفسر ما يخفى عليه ابن عثيمين يشرح
في الدماغ الطبيعيه للنساء قال وهي تختلف
كما كان متنبي وانتفك الانام وانت منهم
فان المسك بعد دم الغزالي وش معناها يا
اخي البيت هذا عبقري فلسفه هذا يقول لي
يقول سيف الدوري يمكن فكت على الناس وانت
من ضمن الناس لكن فان المسك بعض دم
الغزالي المسك المسك من دم الغزل مع العلم
انه مسك لان الغزال في هض مقلوع من الغزال
في هذا التبت في الصين يعني يسقط فروه غده
فياخذونها فيضعونه في سير مسك ولذلك
الغماري محدث مغربي
في شرح حديث نظر الله امرا سمعه مني
مقالتين يقصد هذا في المتنبي
وانت منهم فان الغزالي جاء بن عثيمين من
امريكا تعالج عن السرطان الله يرحمه
فاستضافوا الشيخ عبد الله بن راشد الجاري
في الرحمانيه ودعاني قال كيفكم يا شيخ عوض
لاني انا من اسرار تلاميذي وصاحبتهم
ونفعني في مواقف الله يبيض وجهه قلت والله
يا شيخ قال كيفكم كان في اخبار الشعر طبعا
هو الشيخ مسخر معه الدكتور عبد الله اخو
وناس ما هو مناسب يتفصح قلت يا شيخ انا
الشعر كما يقول متنبي العلم معه في اذ
عوفيته الميت
العلم في عوفيت والكرم ووزال عنك اذا عداء
الى اعدائك الالم وما يخصك في برء بثانيه
اذا سلمت فكل الناس قد سلموا والمجد المجد
لانه المتنبي يقول سيف الدوله المريض يا
اخي من يقول هذا الكلام شوف حتى اذا مرض
الكبار عندنا ياتون في التويتر كلهم كذا
المجدعه وفيت والكرم وزعل عنك لعدائك
الالم وما يخصك في برء بثانيه اذا استلمت
فكل الناس قد سلموا والله يا شيخ اني اعيش
معه بيتين له اني اعود ارتاح واهدى واشوف
حتى يقول يقول يا شيخ الواحد والخوارزمي
عروسه شعله قوله قوله يا حبيبنا يقول كم
زورت لك في العرب داهيه ادهى وقد رقدوا من
زوره الذيب ازورهم وسواد الليل يشفعوا لي
وانثني وبياض الصبح اغريبي وواجب مفكرين
يا اخي عده مفكرين واذا مع المتنبي
ويستشهدون بالمتنبي وعايشين معه فيعني
انما قدمت لانه في برنامجك مسموع ومشاهد
ومن حقي اني اقول يعني ابدا
ابو هشام يقول ان العرب لم تجتمع على شيء
الا على امر التوقي
من اللي اولا اجتمعوا ولا
درون عن امراه شوقي ولا العرب ما دارون
السعوديه بكاميرا ما درت عن هذا وهو بيني
وبينك وقال حافظ ابراهيم يقول يقول انه
راح حافظ ابراهيم يقول امير القوافي قد
اتيته
في محاضره عامه والله يا شيخ مصري عشان
رحت عند شوقي انا احفظه طبعا وين
صادق شوف فاتيت ادور ابغى حي المصريين
الشعب المصري في محاضره فاروح احافظ
ابراهيم القصيده ويوم في المحاضره قال اني
ارى وفؤادي ليس يكذبني شعبا يحف به
الاجلال والكرم ارى جمالا انا رورا ارى
قلقا ارى محي يحيينه ويبتسموا الله اكبر
هذا الشعب نعرفه هذا هو النيل هذا المفرد
العالم هذا اللي يقولوا يقول ثقاف انه
مجامله والامير شو هو شاعر شوقي مانكر
يمكن من اعظم شعار عاصمه المتنبي
ابن تيميه استشهد للمتنبي بحول 20 بيت في
كتب والله يا شيخ اني نقول يمشي شوي كما
يقولوا وكيف يصحوا في الاذان اذا احتاج
النار الى دليل شوفي البيت انت صادق ولست
يعني يجري مع اللسان يجري انا دخلت والله
شيخ مع الزعماء والملوك واني اسمع الابيات
في المجالس من المتنبي المتنبي حاضر مع
العامه حاضر مع المتخصصين حاضر ولذلك
يعني اذا حتى انه احيانا
اشارك بعض الاخوه يقول انت شفت يقول هنا
بادن هواك صبرت ام لم تصبر بوبكاك اذا لم
يجلس جمعك او جرى كم غره قبلك قبلك
واستبارك
سالت الفيلسوف اسمعني عبد الله الشيخ عبد
الله في جده انا ترى اذا ذكرت المتنبي
يرفع عني القلم يا ابو عمر
ودك نوقف لا لا طولت
سمعت اللي فيها قبل كم يوم
احدهم يقول انه اشعر من المتنبي جاك
المقطع لا هو يقول عن نفسه عليه والله هذا
علاج انا بقرا عليه مستعد مع القراءه كي
انا ببرك على صدري واقف الكرسي مع الكي
وانا عندي واحد اسمه الصمعاني يكوي كويس
فانا معك يا حبيبي دلوني عليه دلوني
يا حبيبي
المتنبي ذا اني اجد العلماء واجد الشعراء
والفلاسفه حتى يقول يقول يقول احد المشايخ
تاريخ حظنا الله يا اخي وهذا الشيوع تعرف
شرح ديوانه اكثر من ثمانين شارع والله شيخ
اني كانوا بيفسرون كيف
يروح عند ابن العميد شوف الاعجاز راح قال
كفانا الربيع الطلق من بركاتي فجات ولم
تسمع روغانس والرعدي اذا ما استحينا الماء
يعرض نفسه وقرانا بسبته في اناء من
الورديه اختلفوا فيها وشرقوا وغرب وجاء
الواحد يوحل المساله اذا هذا من عبقريته
في مجموع الرسائل الشوكاني يقول هو
المتنبي كله دمع يسيل منها عليها وبفك
اليدين من ويتخلى تدرس مقصوده يقول كل دمع
يصير من الدنيا عليها منها عليها يقول اذا
بكيت منها ترى نبكي عليها حب لها هي
تبكينها اصلا ونبكي لكن نبكي عليها وقالوا
حنا متعلقين مثل الطفل
امسك بشيء من شر فمه شو ما تفكه الا
بصعوبه قالوا بترك اليدين منهم تخلى يقول
الشوكاني لا اله الا الله ما ادق نظري انا
اغوص يسخ في البيت واجلس احلل معه كيف كيف
يصل الى هذه المعلومه الى هذه الى هذا
الابداع
واستعرض شروحه انا يعني هذا شيء اخر عندي
واذا هم يا اخي
ذهبي مؤرخ الاسلام يقول ليس في الدنيا شعر
من اما مثله ولذلك انا لا اقول لا تاخذ
بكلامي او كلامه افضل مني وهو اخي وحبيبي
واتقرب لكن المجتمع انت تدخل الجامعات
وادخل
الميادين الثقافيه والابداعيه وادخل
قبيلتك حتى العوام والله اني اسمع العامي
المتنبي لانه فيه بدعي يا حبيبي
ولا شاعر
في شعر هو غريب عليه هذا ليس منصفا ابو
العلا في هذه الكلمه يقول انا ابو تمام
وانا انا وابو تمام حكيمان والشاعر
المحترم بل هو شاعر وحكيم حتى يكون حتى
شعره في الحب ترى من اروع الشعر من اروع
الشعر لكن لما غلبت عليه الحكمه ولا تصوير
الحب يقول السقاف يقول اسال الله لمن اتى
بهذا الابداع في هذه القصيده ان يحرم وجهه
على النار اسمع يقول يقول يمدح الفتاه
فتاه الفتاه اللي يحبها ديار اللواتي
دارهن عزيزه بحمر القناه يحفظ لنا
بالتمائم يقول اهلا قبيله يحفظون
ما هو عليها وخلاص
وتميمه يقول يقول
يحفظنا بالتمائم الديار اللواتي
التثني ينقش مثله اذا مسنى في اجسادهن
النواعم حتى يقول حرير الثوب ينقش في
الجسم
ويبسمنا عن در تقلدنا مثله
تراكي قلدت بالمباسم التراقي در وهذا در
اسمع والله انا اخذتها انا في عاصفه الحزم
لما سويت لبيك يا سلمان كانت محاضره
استدعوني الجيش ارسلوني من هون الدوله الى
الخميس كان قائد القاعده اللواء محمد بن
صالح العتيبي كان نبغى محاضره فيه عاصفه
لبيك يا سلمان جينا اليوم لعيون الوطن
بعزك يا زعيم المملك يا ابو فهد حنا جنود
الله بعين ارواحنا
جنود الله بعين الروح انا بغلى في جنه
الفردوس موعد لكن قلت ودي ابحث عن العربيه
اللي
يصادف الحزم اللي تبناه ملكنا فاتى
المتنبي قال من الحزم ان تستخدم الجهل
دونه اذا اذا كثرت فنجان طرق المظالمي في
الحلم ترك المظالمي وان ترد الماء الذي
نصفه دم فتسقى اذا لم يزاحم يوم من عرف
الايام معرفتي بها وبالناس
بمرحوم اذا ظافر ولا فرد الجاري عليهم
باذني
ايش هذا يا شيخ يعني اوقف العلماء شوف
الغزالي في الاحياء يمشي معه ثم يقف وابن
القيم وابن تيميه ابن خلدون ابن رشد
فسبحان الله باك يا شيخ ما لا يوجد ديوان
عربي ترجمه باللغات مثل المتنبي لا يوجد
ولا يوجد امه اخذت من شعر العرب مثل ما
اخذت من شعر المتنبي
ولا يوجد كلمات سجلت في سجل حافل للمبدعين
كشعر المتن المتنبي شوقي يجب قصائد طويله
وكثيره ولا تمسك منها بيت اشوف يعني والله
اني حاولت اني جيت بالديوان وحاورت اجيبه
من هنا وحاور تجيبه من هنا محاوله
انا خليني
[موسيقى]
هو متنبي اصلا قلته من ضمن الجلساتي وفي
عصر واللي معه قصته
دحين خلاص
كنت انا في ام بي سي مع الدكتور سعد
البريك كان يحاورني هو يقدمني فسالني هو
يعرف الجواب لكن عشان الجمهور المشاهدين
قال يا شيخ المجامله نفاق قلت له ليست
نفاق هذا مداراه مثل ما قال سعد من جدران
وانت لو حصلت لك في الزمن وجه غريب مثل ما
قال مثل دام تمشي مشى اثار هو كان موجود
عند الشيخ خالد الابراهيم في بيتي في
الرياض فلما خرجت من الاستديو واذا عبد
الغني البكري صديق يسمعني الان يسمع
البرنامج متابع قال ترى سعد سمعناك في يوم
جيت بالبيت قلت هم عندك ابو محمد من جهه
الانبيشه قلت اعطني قلت يا ابو محمد عشاك
الليله عندي في رمضان جاي اتعشى عندي بعد
السمره قلت الان انت يا ابو محمد ما خليت
احد حتى مدحته لا شيخ ولا امير ولا وزير
ولا حارس عماره ولا ان لما تحت بقي واحد
ما مدحتها سبحان الله ما اكتشفت شيء قال
ما انا قلت الواحد الاحد الواحد القهار
قال والله انت يا شيخ عندكم مراجع يعني في
الدين قلت عندك انت المراجع اكثر قالوا
قلت الكون الشمس والقمر والنجوم والكواكب
والجمال راجعه قال ابشر بس والله ابشر بعد
فتره كلمني
ثلاث في التوحيد يقول من ضمنه يلا يا ملان
عادل بخوف منه خوف لا شريك الا في ملكه
ولا لعبه سواه فيك تشخيص البصائر ومدات
الكفوف يا كريم يكرمون الاكار من عطاه
عالم اللي معلمه شايف اللي ما نشوف خايفين
سره ولا سره ما هي بتخافاه لا جفان القل
ولا روابحهم ضعوف جار ربي ما يرينا ولا
انقفل الباب من رزق حراسه وفقوف فتحت بما
رزاق من كل الاتجاه الى اخر ما قال قصيده
ثانيه ايضا ثالثه المهم شفت واحد من بيشه
يقول في مجلس انه راهو في المنام بعد ما
مات قال كيف انت يله طيبه وفي ثياب وفي
حديقه قالوا الشيخ غفر الله لي مدحته
ولذلك في الصحيحين اما ان لا احد يحب
اليهم مدح من الله وفي عند احمد في المسجد
اما ان ربك يحب المدح هذه وقفه يعني هو
شاعر بنفسك وقصيده تعرف انت تعرفه ودنا
بالطيب بس
تجيب كان عاده سالم حبيتك يخشها وذمته ما
هي المصيبه
وكل ما حبيت المحبه مع حبيب قام يسحب فيه
مشايبها الى اخره فتقول يعني كنت
شوقي لا هذا في الشعبي انا المتنبي قصدي
ما بنجدلان هنا قصدي في الشعبي لا العربي
لا العربي اذا جينا اذا جينا نقار الشوق
يجعله في مسار طبعا
نزار قباني يمكن
الجواهري هذول اربعه رواد في عصر شعرك
كبار وقبلهم اربعه ان الشيخ هذا التخصصي
انا مشيت في هذا الادب لكن متنبي يا شيخ
اجتمعوا ما هو انا يعني شوف الكتاب
السعوديين اكثرهم على المتنبي العلماء
يعني ولذلك استشهادات انت لا تاخذ بكلامي
لكن انت شوف العلماء وانظر الجامعات وانظر
كيف اسمه يعني يا اخي سبحان الله مؤثر
وليس بيني وبينه انا نسب ولا ميراث انا ما
ورث من شيء
يصنع الكلمه حتى يقول داري دكتور كان اسمه
عبد اللطيف كان يقول يا اخي يقول يحتاجه
تحرير كيميائي كيف تحلل الكلمه يعني ولذلك
حلل العلماء طيب بالنسبه
لغازي
حاكيني عن قصه
يمكن اول مره اقول القصه بالتفصيل لاني
معك يعني وجدت
يكون متنبش يقول هنا يقول متنبي هنا يقول
من الحزم ان تستخدم
ولست بعالمي يقول من ضمن
يقول قطف الرجال والقول قبل نباتي وقذفت
ان تلقون لما نور يقول اذا جاك ميدان
وميزان فوق طفل الكون لها معنى انا اقصد
السيبر رحمه الله الدكتور غازي القصيبي
طبعا كان فيه جفوه ليش ترمي حماس الشباب
انا كنت ذاك الوقت اخطب خطب فكان يكتب
مقالات عن تحرير المراه وكذاك الوقت عندنا
المرحله انه تحرير مره نعناع يعني كفر
عندنا ونتاثر بالغرب وتعرف وجهون الشباب
واهل الحاره فجي اكتب قلت والله لا يكون
هذا وغيرك من الله وكان يكتب هو في عين
العاصفه في ازمه الخليج وانا في ازمه
الخليج الحمد لله وقفت مع السعوديه وتجنت
انا والشيخ سعيد مسفر في الاحتياطي
فكتبت فيها خطبه قويه
فكتب كتاب هو
لحتى لا تكون فتنه اتق الله على هذا
الكلام من ضمن المستوى الموجوده
وكان لا يوسوس لك زملائك واللي حولك انك
خميني السعودي
في الكتاب ثم اعطى الكتاب الملك فهد
والملك فهد صاحب حكمه مرويه ارسله البنباز
يقول يعني حاولوا تكون وديا يعني ما يكون
تعرف اطياف في المجتمع والحاكم دائما يريد
جمع الشمع بن باز قالنا قال لنا يعني سكت
الموضوع ولا عاد تقول يعني لا اتكلم ولا
سكتت وسكت هو والله ما قصر رد رد ما هو
بسهم ماشت الايام وفي جافوه كذا فاتي
فاكتب كتاب امبراطور الشعراء المتنبي صاحب
يعني طبعا وحللت للدكتور غازي القصيبي
لانه هو يعيش مع المتنبي لا تقترب لا تقول
لغاز القصيبي ترى في شاعر ثاني لا خط احمر
فارسلته كان سفينه السعوديه في لندن فلما
وصل طبعا في جفوه سابقه وما في احد سلام
ولا شيء وكت رساله خطيه فرد بارسال الخطيه
قال وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
ويلتقي الحديث فيعرض هذا وعرض هذا خير
الذي يبدا بالسلام قراتوا كتابك وهو راعي
جنب يعني مدح الا في بيت اريد هناك شك فيه
لانك تقول متنبي يكون متنبي يترشفن من فمي
رشفات هن احلى عندي من التوحيد استغفر
الله بعض الشروح يقول التوحيد العقيده
والتوحيد يقول لا يقصد وانا قلت انه
العقيده وهم قالوا حتى الواحد وغيره الشرح
قال لا يقصدها التمر في العراق اسمه التمر
التوحيد سكت انا ما عليك ما هي بقضيه مرت
يشوف سبب الاصلاح المتنبي جاء هو في
الرياض ونقل اصبح وزير توفي الملك فهد
رحمه الله فاخذت بشتي ورحت على قصر الحكم
وعزل الملك سلمان كان امير الرياض في قصر
الحكم ولما دخلت واذا هم مقبل هنا طبعا
يعرفني في الصوره وفي التلفزيون ابدا
والله يا محب وانا قلته في اكثر مناسبه
انه كذا وقد يجمع الله الشتيتين بعدما يظ
كل الظن الا تلاقي الله يغفر له وادعو له
في انسانيه يا اخي ويتبسم وانه ما صافح
انه حطها من وراه يضمني وقد يجمع الله
الشتيتين بعدما يظنني كل الظن كيف حالكم
بشرنا عنكم وطمنا وصلنا الكتاب واخذت بيده
عليه وتعز عليه في الملك فهد مرت الايام
والتقينا الاستاذ مع الاستاذ تركي الدخيل
في برنامج اضاءته اللي كان فيه العربيه
فلما انتهيت من الاضاءات واذا التلفون
يتصل الجوال واذا غاز القصيم قال معك اخوك
المحب غازي القصيبين استمر الى الامام ولا
تلتفت في الخلف ولا تنظر لمن يتحدث في
الظلام شوف كلمات ادبيه عرفت المقصود يعني
انك زد من الطرح ولا عليكم الحساد والنقد
اعجبه يعني الطرح لان في تاخي وفي تعرف
هذا اللي فلما مات بنته يعني بمكانه
واستغفر الله ادعو له لكن كان وزيرا وكان
مثقفا والعجيب انه من احسن من حل له ابيات
المتنبي يقول متنبي يجيك في كل موقف وهو
حاضر معك الى اخره هذا يعني باكتظار طيب
يعني بالنسبه للقراءه
لك هل
القراءه ما قبل انك تشتغل اتذكر شفت فيديو
لناصر الفراعنه فكان يعني يمشي في مكتبته
كان يقول اني من يعني بعد ما يعني كبرت
خلاص يعني ما اقرا زي ما كنت اقرا فاذا ما
قرات وانت صغير لا يمكن انك تقرا لما تبدا
معك مشغل الحياه
انا بالعكس
افطر عندي باسم الدكتور ناصر الزهراني في
مكه اليوم افطر عندي بعد الفجر وانا في
المكتبه افطرت معه قال انت اصلا
بتموت في اليوم بيجيك سكت قلت هذا سلوتي
وهذا غذائي ولو ما قرات لكني اقرا والحمد
لله ليش يا اخي انا هوايتي المفضل الكرام
والسير ترى تصير عنده الانسان نهمه وتسير
عند تعلق
وتصير رغبه جامحه الى درجه الادمان مثل
مدمن في شيء والله اني كنت اقرا سواء اعرف
ولا ما اعرف افهم ولا ما افهم في درجه
الجنوب ثاني وثالث متوسط لكن اولى ثانوي
بدات احتكم ان عندي جده الله يرحمها تسحب
الكتاب انا ان يفطر واني اقرا ابشرك عن
الكتاب الزيت والسمن وكل شيء وراح العنوان
الكتاب عندي كصديق اعرف اصدقائي انا اقول
لزملائي قبل فتره قلت انا لما صليت الفجر
كان عندي سبعه وثمانيه قلت اليوم جلست
معاه بالحجر وبعدين سلمت على ابن القيم
بعدين بن خلدون مريت عليه والمتنبي ترى
يتحدث معي من فطور من حبهم يعني وحبي لهم
وحتى لما بيسمع اعز مكان في الدنيا
في الزمان كتابه طيب دور لي شوقي طيب
في محو الاميه
هذه هذه الصوره اللي مكتبتك
نعم يا حبيبي واللي بتشرفني علشان اهدي لك
الجديد ابشر يعني دائما يجيك باريس السؤال
لما تشوف مكتبه بهذه الضخامه هل قرات كل
الكتب لا ما اقول قراته ولكني بعضها كررته
وبعضه طالعته ما في الكتاب اللي مرتي ما
مساله اما كتب فيها فانا ما حضر وسفره لا
تنسى يا اخي اني انا لست مهندس ولست طبيبا
ولا عسكريا انا هوايه الكراه صدقني في
السياره لي كتاب وفي المسجد بعد ما نتهم
الحزبي كتاب وقبل النوم عند عند الكتاب
واعرف اصدقائي في السهر اختار خفيفه قبل
النوم وفي الظهر يمكن امر باشياء العصر
احتكم في كتب محدده الفجر في كتب اقرب الى
الحديث والتفسير فلا شك يا شيخ انه ترى
الوقت طويل لكن عدم التنظيم يا شيخ ابشرك
اكتشفت شيء في حياتي نسيت ما اخبرت واول
مره اخبركم
كنت اتابع الاخبار بشكل عجيب كاني محلل
فتره انفترت يوم جيت الرياض بعدين كرهت
كتاب
50 قاعده للسعاده اللي ما ياكل امريكي
اخذته من مكتبه العبكان قال اغلقي من نفسك
متابعه الاخبار فانت لست سياسي ولا صانع
قرار ولا محلل
واحد يقول والله وش دخلني انا كل ما جاش
يعني حرب في فتنام دخلت فيها
وكل وحتى اهتم يجيني هم اهتم الكوريين
وليش القتل هذا لان الاخبار ما يجيك تحطم
الطائره وضرب وقتل خمسين واحرقت كذا ما في
خبر بسيط رحت نفسي ابشرك منها وجيت على
الكتب قلت هذا اصدقائي اعيش معهم بعدين
يحدثونك العلماء والخلفاء والوزراء بشرك
ويجو معك مره مع التاريخ تعرف الجاحظ في
كتاب الحيوان يقول كتاب هو الصديق الذي لا
يملك ولا يطريق ولا يضرك يكتم اسرارك
ويسعدك
من حمل وما وما امتعه في ردن ان شفت اشجاك
وان شئت اضحكك وان شئت ابكك يا اخي شيء
الكتب تصنع العقول
فتفضل الله لا اجد الشيخ متعه في حياتي
اجمل تصدق اني في القريه كنت اذهب في
الصيف انه بثلاثه شهور او من حولها انهم
يخرجون الى الوادي في القرني ما اخرج واني
فقط من المسجد الى البيت
الى البخاري ومسلم واذا بن تيميه فارتحت
ابشرك
ايش رايك في تكرار الكتب
تكرار الكتب يا شيخ يقول العقاد عباس
محمود العقاد قراءه كتاب جيدا ثلاث مرات
جيدات افضل من قراءه ثلاث كتب جيده وهذا
معه وقع على ذلك قراءته كتاب جيد واحد
ثلاث مرات جيده افضل من قراءه ثلاث كتب
جيدات الكتب التكرار كتاب تخرجك عالما
متقنا الكتب مثقفا تسولف وتعرف العنوان
وبسالفه ونص بيت وكذا اما هذا المتقن
ولذلك يقول احذر من صاحب خف من صاحب
الكتاب الواحد لانه بينقضى عليك ولذلك تجد
لي صاحب كتاب ركز علامه السي بويم التخرج
الكتاب ضغط على نفسه وتجد اللي تخصصه في
الكتاب صاروا محافي العالم وتجد التخصص في
البخاري صار عالم اما المنتشر هذا
دائما الكثافه والعمق يغلب الكثره بقره
سمينه ولا سبع عجاف مره يقول يبنوكم ايكم
احسن عملا ولو ذلك اؤيد يا شيخ تكرار
الكتاب اول مره كراه يعني تذكر وملامح
عامه للكتاب والعناوين القراءه الثانيه
رصد ودخول في القراءه الثانيه فريه ثري
وتحقيق خاصه كتب تستاهل ممكن كتاب
والله انا عندي مثل استطيع اقول لك كتب
الصحيحين ادور في فلكه لان التخصصي حديث
في جامعه الامام
وجمع عبد الحق والع الحميدي هذا فتح
الباري اثر علي بشكل منصور هو اللفه في 25
سنه والمقدمه سبع سنوات
اشتريته بحول 300 ريال لو علمت الدكتور
سعيد المسفر قال الله اكبر جلس فيه 32 سنه
وتشتري بقيمه مندي
لانه ذاك الوقت المندي كان رخيص يعني
شوفوا الجهد يعني كيف المعرفه عندنا كيف
انه رخيصه وعجز الناس ان يكرهه
انا حافظ المقدمه الان من ورعي به الحمد
لله الذي شرح صدوره الاسلامي
وارتاحت لسماعها وامات نفوسها البدعه
بالباطل بعد ان تمارس ابتدائي مشى فيها
يشرح حديث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بتحليل علمي راقي من يقول الالباني لم تلد
انثى اعلم بالحديث من ابن حجر العسكري
الحافظ صاحب فتح الباري ابن باز حضرتك
مجلسه في الطائف قالوا الدكاتره يا شيخ
تعلم فتح البخاري اكثر احسن من فتح الباري
قال لك كما قيل له بعد الفتح لا هجرته بعد
فتره مكاني والفتح الباري لان قال الكلمه
الشوكاني
قيل لهم في صنم العلماء
اليمن كبار ما تشرح البخاري قال له هجره
بعد الفتح خلاص منها الشيخ طبعا في كتب
الادب كتب الادب وكرر تصدق الاغاني يمكن
كررت سبع مرات لابي فاكثر محفوظات الان
كثير من الاغاني اللي بالفرش مره عندي
طبعه بحور 28 مجلد و24 مجلد العقد الفريد
طبعا في الادب التفاسير يمكن ركزت على
خمسه منها ابن جرير ابن كثير ابن سعدي من
المعاصرين
هذا فني تخصصي لاني انا في السير دروسي
اكثره في السير طبعا سيره ابن هشام وزاد
المعاد في السيره
واما السير للتراجم سياره اعلامي انه بلاء
هو الذي اثر عندي كثيرا يقول واحد من
جامعه ام القرى دكتور يقول لا اعلم بعد
الوحي كتاب سطر النبلاء الذهبي طبعا في
طبعا 23 وطبعا انحو الخمسين مجلد لانه
يرسم لك يفصل لك الثوب بالترجمه كانوا على
مترجم وبعدين له عبارات راقيه واديب هو
فاكتشفت ان السر واكتشفت الرجال واكتشفت
حياتهم لانه يعلمك السير يا شيخ تعلمك
الحياه وتعلمك وتزيد في عقلك فكنت اسهر
معه مره اضحك معه مره ايش يجيني
والسياره اشبه بالتاريخ
وفيها من العظات من الله بعبا فيها شيخ
مثلا علم
التفسير انا زاد المسير ايضا عندي لابن
الجوزي رحمه الله
فيها حفظكم الباري طبعا الكتب التي انا
اختارها اضعها على جنب اقرب الاصدقاء
وارجع لموسوعات يعني مثل يمكن من اكثر
العلماء اللي اثر عندي هو بنتي حتى لو قلت
لي العلماء الاربعه
في الفتاه وتداول وكتب وبعد ياتي طبعا ابن
القيم رحمهم الله يعني كثير المقروء لكن
عموما يا شيخ انا ارى اني اعيد ينبغي لنا
حمله ثقافيه واعلنها من برنامجك الى عاده
الناس الى القراءه باي وسيله والشعوب التي
لا تقرا سوف تكون راكده وانما الابداع
والرياده والنهضه لمن يقرا
وترى الاكتشاف هو قراءه ترى
يعني قصدي مخترعين في العالم انا قلت مره
في مكان تكون تقتل في الشرق الاوسط وكان
الملك سلمان الله يمسي بالخير هو من قارئ
نعم من اكثر القراء الذي في حياتي عرفته
انت تعرف هذا مره يتصل بي على في الاسبوع
اكتب كل يوم خميس كان ابنه مسرف على
الصحيفه احمد الله يرحمه العرب لا يقراون
ما قالها موجوده في النت كتبت فاتصل بك
كان احسنت في هذا تصدق اني في رحله يكرهها
ثمانيه كتب صدق امراه
شوف الخلل عند الشباب الان انهم ليس عند
الكتاب ما عند الكتاب هم او لو ليس الكتاب
عندهم اهميه صادق بعضهم اذا التخرج رمى
كتابه كتاب معك حتى تصل يقول الامام احمد
من المحبر الى المقبره في القراءه يعني
لابد منها والعوده الى هذا قدر الاستطراد
في هذا العرب لا يقرؤون هذه الكلمه قلت
الحمد لله ان وجد فينا من يقرا ولن وجد من
من يعود قصدي الخواجه قلت في المقاله اذا
ركبت في طائره ورايت واحد وركب النظارات
وعندهم كتاب ويحلل ويعرف انه خواجه اوروبي
كذا
واذا جلست جنبك واحد سالك عن اهلك وعن
زوجاتك فانت تزوجت وكم طلقت وكيف البيت هو
بالايجار بالقرن
هو من عربي
هم قحطان في شركات
ناس خليها وانا
اول مره في ازمه الخليج ومحتل العراق
الكويت قمت فسويت خطبه في ابها ولدت
بالغزو ثم دعينا لتجنيد الاجباري ما هو
اجباري يعني حنا تبرعنا اذا كان يسمى انا
والسعيد المسفر وموجود صورنا فذهبنا
وتدربنا
قال الشيخ متعب وهو يتابع طبعا برنامج هذا
الشيخ متعب الطيار اسمعوني قال نادى عاض
القني من ابى خليه يجيني وعود قال الملك
سلمان من الرياض طبعا يبغاك واعود جيت
دخلت انا والد الدكتور وليد الرشيدي
قال هذا كان ابغى ارحب
وثلاثين هذه اول مره اول مره لما دخلت
عليه كان الشيخ معالي الشيخ ناصر الشتري
موجود والله من لطافته الملك سلمان يقول
يا شيخ ناصر
بعدين دخلنا في السوالف في الغزو وكذا
وكذا
فاحتفاى واكرمني طبعا بدات الاتصال انا
جلست مع الملك تشرفت يمكن ثلاثين المجلس
اما عام ولا خاص
ويتصل بحرف الجوال مره يصحى ومره مرشدا
ومره هو عاتبا
متى
مره من ضمني من ضمن تحمس سنه في مساله في
شريط القيت محاضره فيها فراجحي
وقلت ينبغي ان ينهى عن المنكر وكنت تعرف
حماس سبحان ويتابع ويسمع محاضرتك او ادخلت
عليه غير شوف عندك علم ولكن مده كان في
عقل
وانا قلت له
عندك اكل يعادل
وش هذا الحماس يقول هو اجلس على وجلس
شوف الشيخ بن باس يعني ادعوا باللطف حماس
شباب
قلت اني كلمت استاذنت من امير متى تحزن
قلت يوم سجنتوني يا طويل العمر في السجن
السياسي في جده قال والله انا اني قرات
تسعين صفحه من واني ارتحت وانشرح صدري
ونعلم انك بتعلم مثلما عندك نعيدك ثاني
مره في وهو في المصيبه
الحضور والجواب ثم تنبعث ثلاث سنوات قال
شوف كتابك يمكن قراته ثلاث مرات وقال نعم
يعني من فضل الله عليه فهذه من قصه يعني
اذكر مثلا مثلا يوم قلت انه يهاجمونا في
الصحافه قال شوف اخر سوره ال عمران قالوا
تسمعونا من الذين الكتاب الى القصص كان في
مصر قال انت متوضي قلت يا طويل العمر ترى
قال ابن سعدي وابن عباس لا بس مصحف
للانسان وهو غير متوضي اخذت مصحفي للقصص
وهو في اخر سوره ال عمران
ويذكرني بالايه ولابد الانسان ان يهاجم
ولابد الانسان ياتي اذى
شك يعني الميدان كثير ويحتاج الى حديث
لحديث كثير في مساله الثقافه مرتين بالرفق
مره يوم وقفت الدعوه ودعاني وقال اذا ما
تحمل طيب الرسول في الخلق هو جمع عليه
الصلاه والسلام
ومره سويت محاضره اسمه حتى لا تارك
السيفين الموجوده في اليوتيوب
فاتصل قال شكرا لك واذا بتحولها في كتاب
ترى انا بطبع الكتاب واعود حط نفقه
الطباعه كلها في الكتاب سويت
واتصل على قال سمعت يعطون المحاضره ويسمع
انت بتفرغها في كتاب قلت نعم
مره وهذا موجود قلت حتى مع
عبد الرحمن البشري اتى في مقال موجود في
النت
الملك عبد العزيز قائد الثوره في موجود في
الشرق الوسط في النت يوم بدات الثورات جيت
بهذا قلت لا نحتاج الى ثوره نحن قمنا
بالثوره وقاده لعبد العزيز بن عبد الرحمن
وجيت باشترك مقر فتح الله عليه وانا ذاك
الوقت رحت باريس علشان ابغى اتعالج من
ركبي مع الامير عبد العزيز بن فهد واذا
بالتلفون يتصل واذا هو
الحارثي الله يحفظك في اللي كان مع
الدكتور الحارثي مع الامير نايف قال
الامير نايف يسلم عليه يقول من احسن
مقالات اللي قرا الملك عبد العزيز
انبسطت واذا اتصال الملك سلمان قال انا
قرات المكان احسنت شكرا لك لكن ترى البيت
وجاب البيت وقصه البيت لانه بنت حيمس اسمه
فهد نجد شامه البو تركي واخذها شيخنا
وخمرت عشاق عقب الاطم خشومه وثم جابز
الذكرة يعني ما هو مجالها الان قصه البيت
وماذا حصل بتاريخ ما كنت ادري بهذا
التفاصيل مره كتبت اول مره اقول برنامج
قلت كتبت مقاله ايضا في الشرق موجود في
النت في جوجل الرجل الاسود في البيت
الابيض بارك اوباما
العفو العام ايضا موجود في
مرجعني لان مقالتي هناك علشان ابسط العفو
العام الشرق الاوسط تقراونه قلت اتخذ
قرارا قبل النوم بالعفو العام عن كل من
اساء لك تنام اجمل ليله اما جيت بيني
وبينك بالادله وطبعا متنبي حاضر معنا
وبن تيميه وهو قارنهم سبحان الله واتصل
علي قال المكان هذا احسنت فيه صنعه ولن
يصعد الانسان الا بان يعفو ويصفح وهو حاكم
ابن حاكم
جلست مره يسمعني قلت معه في المقابل الاخ
عبد الله كنت اتقهوى انا وياه في مكتبتي
واذا يقول كلم الامير سلمان كراميل رياض
كان مع الامير سلطان يتعالج فيه امريكا
كلام يطول العمر قال فين كتابك صناعه
النجوم قلت عندي في المكتب قال افتحه اثار
صلاح
ويناظر فيها قال افتح صفحه 138 فتحت قالت
تقول في عادي بن ابي طالب ثم بويع
بالخلافه ثم قتل بويع في المدينه ثم قتل
قال اكتب قتل في الكوفه لانه ما قتل في
المدينه وانا نسيت هذه السياق العباره
عود كتبت كذا بعدين انت مشيتنا مساله
الرواد مساله الرواد ما ادري فيه من احد
الرواد المسلمين
اللي بنسينا ولا شيء يقول اغفت اليه مثلا
مثل فلان يعني
في الجانب الشريعه يعني ليس تخصصا واحدا
وكان مدافر معي في الجلسه في الاتصالين
كان بينهم يمكن ربع ساعه عشر دقائق وقلت
كذا قصدي اني انا عشت معه الثقافه وعشت
النص معه
هو الذي عادني للدعوه كان عند ضدي تسع
قرارات شفاعل عند الملك فهد وارسلني مره
بن باز ومره مع التركي ويلاحظ علي هدي
الموضوع اترك هذا لا تبحث اكتب لي خطاب
شفع الى معادني فبي الله وجهك وصار طبعا
الله يسدده ويحفظه ويتولى التقيت بالاميره
محمد سلمان التقيت بهم سته مرات نعم اول
مره دعاني وطبعا ما كنت ادري يعني اول مره
اعرف طبعا في الاعلام واشوف سمو الامير في
الاعلام لكن اول مره ارى
دخلت عليه متى الكلام يعني تقدر تقول ست
سنوات او كذا دخلت عليه واذا هو ليس لابس
مثلك الان وحياني وجلسني فجلس بسريع
بالكرسي انا بجانبه طبعا تعرف انه ما ندري
ايش الاخبار وما ادري ايش اللي قدامي قلت
يا طويل العمر ترى يجيكم ناس قدي يبلغونكم
وانا قدامك الان قال شوف انا لو كنت اشك
فيك واحد في المئه ما دعوتك يعني يريح
بالك وانا اريد الصراحه وانا اقول كلمه
انا طبعا مع اسمه يمكن ست جلسات اسلام
يمكن الشعب السعودي والعالم شافوا هذا
اقول باختصار بين قوسين اذا كان في العلم
مجدد ففي الحكم مجدد محمد بن سلمان تجديد
الحكم
يعني مسمى مجدد في الحكم مثل مجدد في
العلم مجدد في الطب مجدد في الهندسه مجدد
في الحكم
العبقريه في الملاحظه في الانتباه في
الاستحضار في الثقافه في اخذ القرار
الحاسوب ولذلك سبحانه عشر الله يسدده
ويوفقه وذلك المتنبي بيحضر معنا يقول
المجد اذا بدك تستدل المتجر وتركه في
الدنيا دويا
كانما تداول السمع المرء المره العشره فلا
تحسبن المجد دفا وقيله فمن المجد الا
السيف والفتكه البكر وتركك في الدنيا دويا
كانما تداول استعمال المراه منه العشره
يقول العقاد اذا اردت تستدل على عظيم انه
عظيم فانظر المحبين والمعارضين وانظروا
الضجيج الذي يحصل ضجيج الساعه ضجه اما
نعادين يمرون في التاريخ في الطب وفي
العلم الشرعي وفي الثقافه وفي الهندسه لكن
التجديد شيء اخر وهو الحسب في القرار
والحزم والمبادره
والتنفيذ المبني على الرؤيه وعلى الدراسه
ونسال الله ان يسعدنا به ويسعده بنا ويجعل
اعماله خالصه وجه الكريم وانتم ملاحظين
ماذا يحصل في العالم وماذا وماذا وما هي
المبادره التي حصلتها
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا اتابعكم
الله يعني
ممتن لهذا الوقت
شكرا لكم شكرا القحطاني وايمن الحمادي في
اعداد الحلقه
وجميل عبد الحفيث في تحرير الحلقه وحابب
موسى خلف الكاميرات ومحمد الحسن في
الهندسه الصوتيه في اداره المحتوى التواصل
نوره السبيعي وفي التلوين عبد المجيد
العطاس
واداره التحرير اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
انشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل